Ladies and gentlemen,
this episode of the podcast is brought
to you by squarespace.
Squarespace is the official number one
only web space,
creating sponsor the best one.
The best.
I mean,
there's no need to use anything else.
If you want to create your own website,
if you need a website,
you should do it yourself.
It's that the technology has reached a
point where I would suggest to people
that need a new website.
Well,
are you specific?
Do you know what you want?
Yet,
when then you could do it yourself.
You could literally do it yourself.
A professional looking website.
With squarespace,
squarespace,
it's the best deal.
I'm actually using them for my sign up
twice.
I'm using it for a second website that I
just started last week and it's amazing.
I know so many people use it.
Kara,
Santa Maria.
Use it to manage her webspace.
I'm Duncan uses it.
It's amazing.
Yeah,
it was funny.
The guys at squarespace when I met him
in New York,
they're like,
we got a,
a,
one of those report tickets when things
are going wrong.
What's that called?
Uh,
yeah.
What's it called?
A ticket
report,
ticket support,
support,
not report.
Yeah,
they got a support ticket for Duncan
trussell and they were like,
is this Duncan trussell Duncan trussell.
We're trying to figure it out.
Squarespace is seriously.
It's one of the easiest things you'll
ever do when it comes to creating
something that looks incredibly
professional.
You can create a unique website for
yourself or your business with a simple
drag and drop interface.
They offer 24 slash seven support and it
works on everything.
It'll work on your iphone or to work on
your android phone or to work on a UNIX
computer or work on a Mac to work on
windows and every site comes with a
unique online version of it.
The mobile version,
rather everything's online with my
daughter,
mom mobile unique mobile version that
matches the overall style of your
website so that your content will look
great on every device.
Every time.
Squarespace also has a logo creator.
We can create a clean,
simple logo d designed for yourself in
minutes and every single website you do
on squarespace,
you can start an online store with it.
Every site comes with an online store.
It's super easy to do.
If you can just attach photos to email
and get around a computer like a normal
person,
you can make your own website.
It's the technology has reached that
point for a free trial and 10 percent
off your first purchase.
Go to squarespace.com
and enter the code word Joe squarespace.
A better web starts with your website.
We're also brought to you by legal zoom.
Legal Zoom is an awesome way that you
can handle a lot of legal issues without
leaving your house.
It used to be that you would have to go
to a lawyer and make an appointment and
pay a lot of money to resolve.
Simple things like power of attorney,
living trusts,
wills,
you can do all that stuff online.
Now through legal zoom.
They've been handling it for over 10
years.
They have an a plus with the better
business bureau and they've helped
protect people's assets with Llcs,
s corporations,
trademarks,
real estate documents,
and more.
Even allegedly.
I mean I've seen it on the website
offered divorce,
but I would like to look at.
I would like to look at how many people
have
actually got divorced through legal
zoom.
A grueling 10 years with legal.
Yeah.
People to it out,
man.
I was listening to this interview with
this guy was talking about how much
money you had to pay.
Some famous guy was telling you mention
his name,
but he's talking about how much money,
how to pay out in a divorce and freaking
out about it.
That's war with some people.
More old stories to say about how your
friend had to pay for his own wife's.
I'm going through it.
I wonder if I could use legal zoom.
Got divorced.
What's his name?
Gary.
Let us get married.
Why would they let us get married and
begin with skin fight?
We can't be married each other.
Anyway,
go to legalzoom.com.
Dad,
why are you marrying him and see if you
can get divorced from your boyfriend or
your husband?
Whatever.
My Dad,
whenever a gay dude says my husband,
I was just go.
Okay.
I got it.
It takes a second.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm not judging,
but you said husband,
right?
Your guy.
All right.
Oh,
okay.
All right,
well don't you believe it's possible.
I'm not homophobic at all,
but if I see and I live in New York
where if you see two guys making out,
you're still like weird word a little
still.
Well it's always going to be if you're a
heterosexual because for the most part
you don't see it until you reach an
adult age and then you're out in the
wild with the wild homosexuals that just
frequent these uh,
thoroughfares and there's avenues and
spot.
Like if you go down Santa Monica
Boulevard and probably we should
probably just start the podcast right
here.
Is there different levels of that where
you look at c,
two people kissing and you're just like,
you know what,
I'm a little hungry for that.
Or like,
oh my God,
that's hot.
Is it at all?
Like on and off,
you think like some people look go to
who?
What are you saying?
Like if you're walking down the street
and see anybody walking on the street,
two guys kissing each other I ever say,
is that,
is it completely hilarious and weird?
Or is it like mildly?
Like,
oh,
I see what they're doing there,
or is it like,
because that seems to be talking to this
question now way,
way before you tried to express yourself
in such a complex manner.
It seems very like I wonder if there's
different levels because I'm,
I'm,
I'm like,
that's hilarious and creepy and weird.
It depends on what the guys look like
because there's a broad spectrum of
masculine to feminine homosexuals just
like there are,
you know,
like women look different,
you know?
I mean if,
if you run into to have a certain type
of women making out,
it's not fun,
but if know it's uncomfortable,
but if you run into women that are just
whatever,
for whatever reason they flow together
well visually,
but if to Brad Pitt's we're kissing or
Brad Pitt and George Clooney never be
hot to me because I'm a straight male,
what I would sympathize,
I would say,
you know what's weird that I would judge
and then I would hope that they don't
run into anybody.
That's mean I do that.
Would you take a photo?
No,
that's rude to have you stolen.
Just make like against a telephone pole.
Depends if someone,
they started taking
their pants off,
I'd probably start filming,
started going after it,
but then you get caught with gay porn on
your phone and then illegally acquired
gay porn.
You're a bad person and you're.
Yeah,
you're not supposed to be just fill in
people.
I don't think you're supposed to just
film people,
you know.
I don't know what the rules are like
about.
I guess if you do something publicly
should be assumed that you're filming
it,
but if you just took film of some guys,
make it out and put it on Youtube.
If you make a website called Joe News,
you could just say you just hang one of
those signs around your neck,
like when they do for TV shows,
like filming in progress to assume that
you will be shown.
Yeah.
Legalzoom.com.
That gives a codeword Rogan.
He goes out with all these questions.
I don't think they can do.
You can hire an attorney.
Legal Zoom was developed by top
attorneys to provide self help services
at your specific direction,
but they're not a law firm.
Um,
they will provide you with a third party
attorney though if the shit hits the
fan.
I have to say all this before we get
done with this.
Otherwise we'll be stuck in this
commercial for an hour.
Anyway,
we've,
we've used legal zoom.
Brian used it to a form desk squads.
Aubrey used it to make on it.
It's a,
it's an awesome service.
So you go to legalzoom.com
and use the codeword Rogan.
And last but not least,
we're brought to you by [inaudible] dot
com.
That is o n n I t a human optimization
website.
And on it is right now releasing the
newest of our artistic kettlebells,
Werewolf Kettlebell,
the legend bells.
We have the Zombie Bells of course,
which I think we're out of.
I think that's what's going on.
The website here,
I'm sure there's armed rebels were out
of them.
Still have the great apes.
We still have some of those and we will.
I'm sure we'll have the Zombie bills
back because they were fucking awesome.
We've got some other ones that are
coming out too.
We've got some new ones.
Oh,
that's nice,
man.
Yeah,
the wearables dope,
it's heavy as fuck to the Werewolf is a
big one.
It's 65 pounds,
28 kilograms,
60 to 62 pounds,
so it's a good one to work out with
hurt.
They hurt if you do any kind of like a
foot to flip it over and your risks.
Like I used to do one with a skull and
yeah,
we just cracked my wrist.
Well you got to do is first of all,
you got to make sure that the face is
outside facing the opposite direction.
That's a simple solution.
I guess that's what you do,
but that's hard to do when you're tired.
But the other thing is you got to learn
the technique of like punching through.
Like when do you swing a kettle bell?
There's a certain amount of control that
you develop with it where it doesn't
ever hurt your arm because then like a
lot of times people when they're
starting out especially they'll put like
risk things on like they're trying to
get an eagle to land on their arms
cushion things so that when the
Kettlebell flips and hits it,
it doesn't hurt.
But you get,
you get to know what,
what's moving.
You're supposed to like twist it sorta
twisted towards you first and then as
you're going up you sort of punched
through it and then it's a.
If you do it in a smooth motion,
never really slams in your arm.
But the thing is if you're doing them
right,
you're going to get tired.
When you get tired,
that's when your techniques suffers.
That's when you can.
You could fuck yourself up.
Oh,
techniques.
Suffering is.
I've done some doing crossfit.
I did so much damage because I just
never.
We've worked hard on good form.
It's so important.
Yeah.
Welcome to the club.
There's so many people that have hurt
themselves doing that kind of stuff.
Those a power lifting exercises,
you know,
especially I'm Steve,
I'm a maxwell who's a real expert in
fitness and the guy who's,
he's in incredible shape,
he's 62 years old.
You guys are just an animal and just a
wealth of knowledge.
He's not a fan of those type of workouts
because he said that those power lifting
workouts should all be done with very
strict form and very heavy weights and
very low reps and he's like,
so they're essentially taking these,
these workouts that are all about this
one big explosion and the most you can
get up and they're doing them over and
over and over and over and over and over
and some people can get away with that,
but some people get really fucked up.
Well,
they also have the element of like
competition to it,
which I never really bought into because
I was just doing it like trying a lot of
weight and get in shape.
So I just.
I looked at it as like whatever was on
that board was my workout,
but there was a competition element so
it is funny that they spend.
But the first 15 minutes of any crossfit
class I've done is showing you the form
of today's workout is the proper dead
lift.
This is a proper clean power clean,
and then they do that for 15 minutes.
Then they go,
all right as fast as you can now for
seven minutes,
and it's like crazy,
you know,
and these people are competitive people
and they want to win,
so gosh,
just like you just see how they're bent
over the wrong way and just like putting
so much on your back for anybody that's
thinking about doing any kind of workout
with either kettlebells or even just
regular weights,
just dumbbells or barbells,
please start off slow.
If you've never done any workout before,
working out is all about.
It's tearing down your muscle fiber and
then heels and when it heals,
it gets stronger.
You have to tear it down and then you
have to recover.
The recovery is one of the most
important parts and that's one of the
things that fucks up a lot of athletes.
It's one of the number one issues when
it comes to wrestlers,
like a lot of wrestlers because there's
so mentally tough.
They overtrain they fuck their whole
body up because your body's never
getting the proper rest.
You don't.
If you're not a competitive athlete,
that's in some sort of a program.
We can't.
You can't decide how much workout you
you have to do because you have to
follow a team.
If you're not in that kind of an
athletic program and you can do it
yourself,
be fucking smart about it.
It's hard to do because everybody wants
to just.
God Damn it,
I've been a fat ass.
I've been eating donuts and drinking
cokes.
I need it just I'm going to clean up my
diet and I'm gonna work out like an
animal.
If you do it too hard,
too quick,
you rip things apart,
you will.
You're.
Your body's not developed for it.
You've got to build up to those kinds of
workouts.
That's why.
That's why like steroids.
That's what they do is they help you
heal fast.
He could work out harder.
I think it's such a funny misconception
always,
but steroids were even in movies that
would make it like,
you know,
it's like they stick steroids and
druggos arm and he could just win
fights.
You know what I mean?
People always treated with Barry bonds
like that.
They were like,
he takes steroids,
like he injected into his arm so we can
crack home runs they go,
still requires a ton of extra workout.
It was gonna work harder still than
anybody else.
Definitely,
but you definitely have an advantage
over everybody else who works on it
without an argument.
I mean none of these guys are taking it
and then
just being world leaders are taken and
working out like demons and then being
world beers.
Yeah,
there's a lot a lot going on with that
stuff,
but the real problem with it is the
crashes,
their endocrine systems fucks up their
body.
I was watching this,
this thing on bodybuilders,
men's videos watch this online where
this guy was interviewing a bodybuilder.
I responded to them.
It's my timeline yesterday.
It's the craziest shit ever.
Has Dude who was a big time competitive
bodybuilder,
talked about how he got into it and
talked about all the stuff that he was
dumping into his body and it's like,
whoa,
fucking pain pills every day.
Vikatin steroids this,
that is his kid.
He's like 30.
His kidney was like ready to go.
Like they were like,
dude,
you're going to be on dialysis in a
year.
Like it's over.
Like you're going to have to need new
kidneys.
Like you're usually just crashing the
whole party.
Just take giant purple,
fucking great monster.
What needle marks and fucking feigns
everywhere and they just get addicted.
Get addicted to that thing of sticking
chemicals in your body and make your
body bigger and training like a monster.
You'd call them a junkie too if it was
like if you saw what they did,
they have like,
you know,
a plate or we.
I grew up with,
my stepfather was a competitive power
lifter,
so he was a new.
A lot of friends who were bodybuilders
and stuff.
And you see these guys have like a plate
of pills in front of him everyday.
Oh my God.
Wow.
That's so crazy.
Chunky behavior.
Not Yeah,
that's not a healthy folks,
but yeah,
junkie behavior exists in a lot of
forms.
Existing gambling.
Gambling is the big one.
I'm around so many people.
I know so many people that have really
crazy gambling problems.
That video they just put up,
keeps going to be on the podcast.
We're working it out right now.
It looks like he'll be on October 10th.
Really looking forward to having him on
and talk to him that the video is the
best workout video I've ever had.
The extreme kettlebell cardio workout
series.
They're so brutal.
It's all you need folks.
You don't need a gym membership.
DVD cost 30 bucks.
You take one Kettlebell,
a 35 pound Kettlebell in.
It will fuck you up.
I mean literally you don't need any more
equipment and that Kettlebell will be
around to the end of time.
It's solid metal.
Those things,
they're so fucking durable.
You never have to worry about them
breaking.
I mean you buy one,
you have that for life.
You can pass those things including the
artistic ones,
the Werewolf and the chimpanzee.
Those are solid cast steel.
I mean those are iron kettle bells.
These are like the old Russian metal.
I guess it's.
I guess it's iron,
but the Russians were the ones who
develop these things.
This,
this design.
I mean,
there's some of them,
they make some of them that are like
aluminum on the outside of their,
kind of waited on the inside.
These are not those,
these are solid,
solid metal and they're awesome.
You can't get like any better quality
kettlebells.
We found the best ones you can get
online and they're a little more awkward
in some ways to lift with then some of
the what they call competition
kettlebells that are larger kettlebells
but lighter.
But that awkwardness I think is good.
You know,
everybody's trying to do fucking
comfortable with these God damn things
they're difficult to use and I do.
That's how I do
my squats.
Now I've put a 70 in each hand and do
those things.
It's awesome.
Go all the way down to your ass,
touches your calves and just think
you're fucking fighting for your life.
Think that Werewolf's are chasing you
and shit.
Are you holding onto it?
I do.
I think they're like my life's in
danger.
I think I'm like,
I'm on a hunting trip,
but I'm trying to get up a tree and a
bear's chasing me or something like
that.
Were Werewolf ones like or like right
here going.
It's probably so we're referred to that
kind of trading.
It's like a like apocalypse trading
because all functional movement.
Yeah.
What could you do?
Functional movement is like,
it's huge doing pull ups and stuff like
that.
Even just those basic movements like
it's amazing how I can't do a pull up
still.
Like if I was,
if I remember always feeling that
feeling.
If you were like falling from a building
movies,
they'll catch themselves in the legend
there.
Like going to delay me dying for a
couple more seconds.
Like I could not possibly pull my bot.
Maybe.
Maybe with an adrenaline shot I shoot
up,
but something tells me if I had to pull
my own body weight up a building,
I'd be gone.
If you got to catch yourself by hand,
you'd have to be like one of those park
core dudes shirt,
super gymnast dudes.
Most of us would just spazz off the
building and fucking crashed to our
death and we're gonna be at coke nails.
They would promise Werewolf evoke nails.
Have you ever seen those Russian guys
who go out on like the cranes?
I can't watch that much.
It makes my legs feel weird.
A on a.com
o n and N it.
We don't have to end this mean we can
end this rather.
We don't have to do any music.
Fuck it.
We're just talking a use a codeword
Rogan and save 10 percent off any and
all supplements.
A lot of new shit in including,
uh,
if you haven't had it yet though.
The warrior bars,
which are the most awesome fucking thing
ever.
This thing that we had made a,
it's an ancient lakota recipe.
It's a organic buffalo meat.
I'm bringing stacks of these when I go
up to Alaska,
no antibiotics,
no added hormones,
and it's got 14 grams of protein and a
140 calories.
Four grams of fat for every two hours
serving very healthy for you.
All kinds of cool shit on it.
And again,
use the codeword Rogan save 10 percent
off any and all supplements Bra and cue
the music.
Is it fucking up again?
Now you'd say he didn't want to do
music.
So I.
Oh,
you already unplugged it.
That's how wonky are fucking system is.
Needed.
A better system,
but we can't just unplug play.
I usually unplug it just.
And nothing bad happens.
Like in the middle of it,
I get like an instant message or
something.
And you're like,
what the fuck was that?
Did you get instant messages on your
ipad?
No,
but I'm saying if something like that
were to happen,
you know,
bigj lit up dog.
Yeah Buddy.
Thanks for coming in,
man.
Thank you for having me.
It's very exciting.
But is that,
is that an e cigarette?
You know,
Congress is trying to fucking band those
finally.
That's fine.
The stepping in,
the government's stepping up and ending
these evil,
evil e-cigarettes that are stealing
money from the mouths of the babies of
the families that own the tobacco
companies,
which is Marlboro.
Who makes your preferred brand logic.
And I deal with the logic zero.
No Nicotine.
Yeah.
Oh,
I see,
so it's like a,
just a habit thing.
Crutch.
Yeah,
but I haven't actually looked yesterday
on my 29 days from a year.
That's interesting.
Like a zero tobacco thing that just
fills the habit because it's just a
habit,
a pure water,
pure water vapor.
Wow.
And there's no feeling whatsoever.
Do you get like a little mental thing
that happened?
Was mental thing?
Yeah.
When I get the itch to go with things
I've always wanted to do.
What are you putting up?
They just a New York just said that now
a e-cigarettes are allowed to have paid
commercials during movies now and this
is not,
they haven't had that for 16 years since
regular cigarettes were.
Wait a minute,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
You mean before the movie?
Like paid product placements.
Oh,
but wait a minute,
that's not a product placement.
Is that before the movie or in the
movie?
Hey,
product placements in films has been off
limits for tobacco companies for 16
years,
so now they're allowed to have paper.
Like in movies there's,
they're allowed to be paid.
So what you're saying is like if you
watched the incredibles or whatever and
they'll pull it out.
Cigarettes,
they're getting paid for that.
It's white story.
Well,
I was going to say,
um,
oh,
what's the November man with the new
one?
With the peers fellow.
So if he's smoking a cigarette,
it's one of those things,
right?
If he gets paid to do it,
that's so weird.
That's that they do that on television,
you know,
like you'll,
you'll only be able to use like Mac
computers on some shows.
Clearly obvious to.
I was using number American idol and
every judge happened to be drinking a
coke turned out to the right.
Well there's that too.
And there's just,
there's also like on certain shows,
like you'll see everything.
Even movies you'll see,
like every product is a Sony and they'll
say they'll close up on the Sony phone
when someone gets a phone call.
So you see the Sony logo and it'll be on
a vial laptop and you'd go,
oh,
Sony has a deal in this movie
actually when it's not so many,
it seems like it's always like they
always use apple computers and they
always have the sticker over the apple
logo or iphones,
but they have the apple logo covered up
for some reason and like every single TV
show.
So it's almost like apples,
like,
no,
obviously hold on,
you have to pay us to show the APP.
No,
no,
no.
You've got it totally wrong.
Totally opposite.
They don't get paid by apple.
So they cover it up.
That's what it is.
If apple paid them than they would have.
We're not going to advertise your thing,
but isn't it weird that it seems like
every show does use apple products and
all their shows.
They want to,
you know,
there's like a cult of apple in
Hollywood for sure.
You know,
I'm not sucking my Dick,
but I did a show called P diddy's bad
boys or comedy on Hbo.
And that was,
it turns out that was just an entire
season of a TV show to promote Sean John
Clothing.
Really?
Or they made you,
you had to,
were showing John Closing.
Yeah.
You when you did sleep dress and
definitely hip hop clothes.
That's great.
It's really meant you had to wear their
clothes to do standup and all they could
find in my was a short
sleeve like zip up sweater that said,
show you how across the front room.
Oh my God.
That was about 70 pounds heavier than I
am now.
You did,
you did stand up with uh,
Sean John Shirt on because they made you
wear it.
Oh yeah.
I mean I did,
but coming,
if he was at my pant leg rolled up in my
first year of commodity,
I think one pant leg rolled up,
like ll cool J.
I bought it in full wigger.
I went hard on it.
Did you,
for how long?
Just you know what it was.
I figured out.
I started out in a black comedy room and
I just found out I could fucking destroy
if I just went right to them on that
level.
Now I actually load that kind of comedy
and it's fun to expose that.
Like the white guy who goes into a black
room just like,
come on,
y'all know when you buy a bitch or
drank,
that bitch won't go away.
I'm going to go dancing with dead drunk
bitch.
I bought it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Because you know every job you up in a
club where there's a few white guys who
take on that role was zealous intention.
There's a few of those white guys.
There's always like one or two of those
out there to like get known as a white
guy who does black rooms.
How man?
Well,
yeah,
Gary.
Oh,
and I've watched him.
It blows my goddamn.
I have no idea.
It's like,
let's say it's like listening to what?
What's funny is that when you,
if they turn the microphones off on the
audience,
you'd be like,
and you said there was all black people
in the audience.
You'd be like,
well,
they're probably furious right at what's
happening.
Like the basically being called clowns,
like they won't understand a white guy
unless he does this and then you turn on
the volume of the audience and they're
just roaring high five and just losing
their shit and he'll see like,
really?
It's such like a.
it's such a grand scheme.
Pander.
It's blows my mind.
You're allowed to do that panda though.
As long as it's positive,
you're allowed to do that.
Pander.
Good.
It seems phony.
It seems so phone.
It seems really funny because there's
guys I worked with in the black circuit
when I started that like fantastic
comics,
black like bill burr used to do some of
those rooms,
you know,
but isn't it weird that like no one has
any issue whatsoever with a black guy
who does like alternative comedy,
like that really dead Pan,
you know?
No one's going to white,
nerdy comedy.
No.
No one would say he's taking on the
affectation of the white nerds.
No,
but I'll tell you what,
that guy eats shit.
And a real black comedy room.
He the black right?
The black.
The black nerd is not accepted by the
white guy who acts like a black guy eat
shit and a lot of white comedy clubs.
Yeah.
That's what happened when I first came
to New York and I would say,
wow,
it's so crazy that they make you wear
their clothes.
This lady would not stop hunting.
You couldn't for say.
No.
Couldn't say as a part of the part of
the deal.
Yeah.
There was also some contract where a in
that where it's like he was your manager
for like three years beyond that show or
something like managerial cut of
anything because assuming anything you
got
a moving forward from pdds baby boys of
comedy somehow was because because of p
diddy.
That's no joke man.
I've seen that in reality show
contracts.
I've seen that we're friends,
we're thinking about going on a reality
show and they brought the contract to
someone and it turns out like say if
you're like,
ah,
you know,
if they created some new show,
like a real housewives type show,
and then you became like the breakout
star and took off and had like cookbooks
and shit.
Like a lot of these chicks do and
started making bank.
They get paid.
They get a big fat piece of that.
Man That's not all yours on some of
these contracts.
Oh yeah.
Because you'll be.
It'll even be called like oxygen
networks,
whatever chick presents.
Yeah.
It could be when you're allowed to use
that in your credit,
you know,
like as seen on Sean diddy's,
bad boys of comedy,
you're allowed to use that.
You know what I'm saying?
They'll own you like they're saying that
you have no value other than the value
that they gave.
You mean they own it.
Like they don't just,
they don't benefit from having a
talented person on a show that rewards
them and gives them ratings,
which in turn gives them more
advertising.
No,
no,
no.
They want a piece of your future
prosperity,
your future prosperity based on you
being an entertaining person that they
put on television.
So not only do they want to pay people
just to shit tiny amount of money,
then they want to script what they're
doing,
but then treat them like they're not
even actors.
They're treating them like they're these
weird slaves.
These robots that are out there in the
world.
Yeah,
because I know actors let anybody do
that.
You can't,
you don't get on a Sitcom and they say,
okay,
we own all your book sales and you
fucking,
you know,
anything you do in the movies or
anything from here on.
But the reality stars though,
are you totally against it because
there's some issue of the reality stars
though are completely made by the
network they are though.
But uh,
yeah,
but how is it any different than actors?
Because actors are better at it because
there,
there is a skill there.
Yeah,
there's something.
It's like,
what about the ones that suck?
But I mean like,
do you think like a Snooki should always
give some kickback to Ltv to some
degree?
No,
I don't.
I just recording Ramsey.
Well,
hit singles.
I think those are his shows.
Know he's on like four different shows.
Yeah.
But I think those are his show.
He creates,
you know what I'm saying?
Like he's,
he's a pretty famous dude.
That's not a good example.
And he also has a skill.
It's like he's a world renowned chef.
It's not like Snooki,
you know what I'm saying?
I mean you're talking about the guy was
already famous.
If it depends on what you do though,
if you're like the guy who was on the
bachelor and he owns like a horse
stable.
If after that show,
the horse stables business picks up
huge.
I don't think there should be any
kickback for some like that.
But if he does something moving on like
another reality,
just like the bachelor all stars,
whatever thing.
Sure.
I think to some degree too,
I think that's crazy talk.
I think a person who working for you
when they're doing something like that,
if you're a producer of a television
show or a executive in a network or what
have you,
who I don't know who's getting the
money,
then you hire someone.
You're hiring someone because you think
that they're going to be the best
performer in this production that you're
putting on.
No,
let's stop pretending the reality.
The only reality show is fucking cops.
Okay.
You know,
it's a reality show because one of the
guys got shot and killed the other day
because it's real.
Really,
really hard.
Yeah.
One of the sound guys and they filmed
the whole thing like regular cops style.
Yeah.
The guy got shot and killed the fucking
sound guy.
Did.
That's,
that's the only real reality videos out
there.
No,
it hasn't been released yet.
It's really recent thing.
Um,
but when you're watching a lot of these
shows,
whether it's about selling cars or you
know,
whether it's about being in a pawn shop,
it's all rigged is everybody knows what
the subject's going to be beforehand.
They know what the scenario is,
the painting.
So you're basically an actor,
you're in some quads.
I actor.
Okay.
They can't,
they put you on the show.
Say if we do fucking big,
big Jay's grill house.
And uh,
I decided,
fuck it,
I'm going whole hog.
And then you see like a hog spinning
around thing.
Big Chad do stand up comedy.
But I also love cooking.
So I decided to open up and then they,
they,
what?
They own you,
they own you,
they own a piece of you forever.
Shit.
The reason why they want you on the show
in the first place with some crazy
housewives that fucking gets pilled up
and start screaming at people or whether
you're charlie sheen,
if he ever does a reality show the
reason why they want you because because
they think people are going to tune into
you and they're going to benefit from
that.
Like they can't.
They can't own you because they made you
fuck off.
No,
you're right.
And I guess it is talking about
originally,
I can't remember who you're talking
about.
Not talking about anybody in specific.
I'm talking about these reality shows,
reality shows where they take people.
And you know,
we're talking about him being forced to
wear those shirts and I'm saying that
these,
these shows that like,
like him saying that he was going to be
managing him for three years afterwards.
They,
they connect people in these weird ways
where they'll own you for a long time
after your thing.
They'll get a kickback.
But I guess you're right.
Even in the example that I use,
I guess like Snooki really like she was
cast to do so in essence he is an actor.
When that camera's on you,
man,
let's be real.
It's very difficult for people to be
themselves.
It's just very difficult when the
camera's on you and say ready,
go.
You're performing whether you're
performing in some weird sort of,
uh,
sitcomish reality show.
That's just not,
it's not based on real.
I know what the fuck is really going on.
Like you see Alan Thicke show what data
Alan thicke had this reality show.
You would watch him and go,
why don't you just do a sitcom?
Like it's just so set up.
So set up everything is Gene Simmons,
things like that too,
right?
It's sad and I love him.
Simmons.
I Love Gene Simmons.
You have a kiss shirt on.
I love kiss.
I found a letter the other day that Paul
Stanley's coming in.
I found a letter the other day that I
read.
I wrote rather to some magazine when I
was 11 years old.
Like a kiss letter.
Yeah.
My mom saved it,
so I'm going to bring it in.
Read it to Paul Stanley.
What's it?
What's this new shit?
Don't they have a new set of Gene
Simmons show him and Paul Stanley up
some arena football show.
I don't know what he was
doing,
but the reality show that reality show,
those are hard to watch,
especially with ones like why is Mark
Walberg doing a reality?
Like killing it in life,
but yeah,
but he's getting exposed as being a
doofus by his reality show.
That's what I mean.
It makes them look like.
It just looks like it looks good.
Desperate move.
When it's not.
Well he's not.
He's a narcissistic move.
I think it's that.
I think he probably wants to help all
those other people out.
That's helped his brothers.
Yeah.
He's helping his brothers and his family
out.
It's helping them like actually help
feel like giving them money so it's like
come around a little bit.
I guess having him a part of it without
a doubt.
I mean he's a mega movie star.
Having him a part of it ensures it's
success.
People want to see mark Walberg hanging
around with his family,
period.
I'll watch.
I'll watch a show,
a reality show that I find interesting
to some degree at least give it a couple
of chances.
I couldn't and I.
I've very much enjoyed mark Walberg.
Yeah,
but I couldn't even drum up a reason to
give it a shot to watch that other than
other than other than to watch it for
the wrong reasons and if he's welcoming
that.
That's kind of weird.
Well,
we were saying earlier I think is really
true about these reality shows being
completely scripted,
but the reason why is because these
kinds of shows can happen where they're
just boring.
Nothing's happening.
You know,
if the Kardashians are fighting with
their mom or fighting with her boyfriend
and this guy's out of rehab,
that girl's pregnant.
It's always like something you're tuning
into,
there's always some chaos so they know
how to hook you up with the best one is
the best show by far and I recommend
that actually like watch it,
it's great.
Even if you skim through it on Dvr,
the bad girls club,
I could watch that over and over pieces
of shit.
I mean these chicks are garbage and they
fight online.
They,
they fight over immediately out of the
gates.
It's like,
this bitch thinks she's cute and they're
like,
what'd you say?
Bitch?
And then they ended the hospital fights
fights again to the hospital will,
that's how they stay on television.
Oh yeah.
Then the producers come out and they say
like,
look,
we let you guys fight.
You know,
it happens.
But you did,
you hit her in the,
in the eyeball with a high heel.
So we're gonna we're gonna have to ask
you to leave.
And that's a good teary.
Like,
you know,
I'm going to miss my girls.
It's fucking ridiculous.
Bought with Ohio.
Yeah man.
And,
and people will take things to the next
level because that's how you get
noticed.
If you don't take things to the very
next level,
you don't get noticed.
Yeah,
I mean that's why I mean the UFC such a
great example that buried boxing,
you know what I mean,
like sort of has.
Well the problem with boxing is there's
only like a few big stars that is like a
few fights that you want to see and it's
just going to punch it like the flood
wave of whether my Donna fight this past
weekend,
maybe whether there's a master,
he's a master boxer.
It's beautiful to watch.
I mean,
he really knows how to fight.
I mean he's just one of the rare real
like him and Bernard Hopkins.
James Tony is a good example.
Just a real,
uh,
Andre Ward.
Just boxing masters.
Like if you understand how difficult it
is,
what they're doing,
it's amazing.
But you're watching a guy paint a really
beautiful
picture where in mma you get that too
and you get to satisfy that gladiator.
Hers.
You want to see two guys fight.
I get my ears perk up on any time I see
people fighting on the street or
anything.
It's like,
yeah,
yeah.
Well,
the,
this,
the added elements of takedowns and
chokes and slams and it makes them more
crazy kicks.
And if you're a guy who was a fighter,
if you're a young man who can box the
reason why there's no stars,
I think you're almost like,
oh,
I could probably learn some spin kicks.
And really,
that's such a much more glorious way to
win this.
You know,
the cage,
like,
you know,
Anthony Pettis,
cage kicks,
wins are like the prettiest thing you've
ever better than any,
you know,
or,
or at least tied with any great Tyson
knockout it.
Uh,
there's that fight that we were talking
about earlier where a student,
as a black girl attacks,
uh,
a teacher and start slapping.
Don't,
don't say what it is and show it.
All right,
we're going to get in trouble for this.
Now there's this world star hip hop.
No,
I think it's the news was on the news as
someone film it with their iphone.
So it happened.
Yeah.
No.
Oh my God.
She's attacking the teacher.
Whoa.
This is crazy.
This chicken just swinging at the
teacher.
Oh,
judo,
hip toss her and held her down.
Whoa,
that's crazy.
That's cool.
Needs crazy.
Joe Clark.
Holy.
They need to lean on me.
Principal.
I think I would have went more crazy.
He handled it way better than if that
chick started slapping me.
Well,
this is.
This gets into the subject of what we're
talking about the other day with a
Anthony Kumiai getting hit on the street
while he's taking photographs.
People don't react well.
Deck.
I reacted very well to getting hit.
He didn't hit back.
A lot of people just hit back when they,
when they get hit and if you're.
Especially if you're a man and you're
hitting a woman,
anytime people are hitting people.
If a woman hits you,
it's fucking dangerous,
man.
Getting punched in the face is like
everybody thinks that a woman could
punch you in the face and you're going
to be fine.
Like,
no.
There's a lot of women that are knock
you the fuck out man.
If they.
Especially if they connect on your jaw,
you can't be hitting people and if you
can't,
you know,
if you do hit people,
man,
you gotta be really careful who you're
hitting because if they hit you back,
like if that guy just decided to tee off
on that check,
I mean you see through her to the
ground.
That's a guy who knows martial arts for
sure,
and he was avoiding all of her hitting
him,
but he wasn't hitting her back.
But if he did,
man,
you're running in flailing your arms and
some guy uncorked one on your face.
You fall back,
you're unconscious,
you're going to bounce your head off the
ground and sometimes people die from
that shit and that's a real problem.
When people get knocked out,
they fall down and they hit their head
on the ground and die.
It's like you're pretty much maybe
having a really bad car accident with
your face,
which yeah,
it's just like that.
It's,
the ground is completely like,
there's,
it resists 100 percent.
Like there's no give to it.
Like if you fall in dirt,
you're going to be probably okay.
You know,
like if you fall in a grassy area,
you'll get a concussion,
but you might crack your head wide open
if you fall on concrete block.
I've seen him like a bowling ball.
You ever talked a bowling ball,
that sound?
Imagine that your head and the amount of
distance that your head travels of,
you're a six foot tall man and someone
knocks you out.
You're probably going to travel a good
five and a half,
six feet.
I mean,
depending on how you're standing,
you go unconscious.
You're,
that's a lot of probably more than six
feet because it's,
you know,
you're going to fall back first to.
I mean there's probably going to be a
lot of momentum connected to your head
bouncing off that concrete.
It's awful.
Those fucking videos freak me out,
man.
It was a five videos,
face kicks and stuff.
I can't believe I'm almost like so
shocked at the mentality of someone that
can do inflict harm on somebody.
I always think that there's a lot of
them out there that people aren't aware
of,
so I'm not shocked when I see it.
I'm always like,
I fucking knew it.
I know there's people like that out
there.
I know there's people that have
experienced this awful shit from the
time they were born.
If you grow up in a household where
everybody's beating the fuck out of
everybody and you go to school and
people beat the fuck out of everybody
and you see abuse and you see people
going to jail left and right and life
has no value and you've seen people die.
That's what you're seeing when you watch
those Worldstar hip hop tapes were a
dudes out cold and guys are running by
just punting them in the head.
I've seen a bunch of those.
Yeah,
me too.
I was always like,
it's like it's shocking that someone can
do it to somebody else.
That's a wake up call for people.
Unless you're in.
If your life was directly threatened and
you were in that kind of a rage maybe,
but I mean once somebody down like I
don't know.
I've been in.
I've been in,
let's say for a,
for a guy my age,
a decent amount of street fights in my
life,
but I've never.
I've never had like a kill urge ever,
you know,
I've lost,
I've won,
but even when I,
when like when it's over,
it's kind of over,
you know what I mean?
I've never like tried to put somebody
like that,
you know?
It will depend on why you're fighting.
Right.
But even if like,
I don't know if it was a guy beating the
shit out of your girlfriend,
you know what I'm saying?
Sure.
You know what I'm saying?
Like what if you pulled up somewhere and
just got there right when a guy was
beating the shit out of your garage.
I'm not saying not to knock them out,
but I mean like to punch somebody's
head.
Like I don't know if that,
I just don't know where my killer rage
kicks in.
Like actual murderous rage.
I don't know where that level is in me.
Yeah,
I think it's pretty deep.
I'm pretty mellow dude.
I've.
Yeah,
but I think if you were confronted,
I mean you might be,
I don't know,
I don't know you,
but if you were confronted by someone
that you were trying to protect someone
that you cared about very much in trying
to protect them,
that some people get murdered us when
they feel like someone is being like
someone's trying to murder someone you
love.
That's when people get murderous,
you know?
That's a common one,
but I'm saying my point is being like a
street,
I promise the situations
where on the world star hip hop videos
where guys are getting face punted,
I promise they weren't.
It wasn't calling for that.
Yeah.
You most likely punting a guy who was
already unconscious,
seen a few of them where it's people
just being drunk.
Idiots laughing,
laughing or talking shit or starting a
fight when they were too drunk and they
got knocked out and then once they were
out everybody just started taking free
shots at him.
Did you oversee that?
It's literally the worst people in the
world quite possibly.
And I think you would agree,
especially someone who's trained in
martial arts,
so use what you have and have you ever
seen that video of the God,
the weird homeless black guy who's crazy
and he goes into the karate studio?
Yeah.
And they kill them and they.
I don't know if he's dead,
but that was supposedly what happened
was he died,
mean the noise he's making after that
access and what's,
what's ridiculous about it.
It was such a,
a cock wagging because the reason that
guy went so far is because when he was
trying to like do a show off,
like Oh,
let me stand up and fight this guy.
And like,
you know,
shut him up.
He wasn't doing very good.
The karate guy was beating his ass in
this fight.
Like that is weird.
I was actually like giving them a hard
time to some degree.
Guy Knew how to fight a little bit,
you know?
The other guy knew how to fight a little
bit.
The guy got killed.
Yeah,
he definitely thinks,
oh really?
Yeah,
enough that he had been in fights
before,
you know,
he wasn't totally helpless.
The guy beat the shit out of him,
but you were right in the beginning.
He wasn't getting the best out of it.
Yeah.
I think the guy had probably mean he
must have had some street fighting.
It was also crazy.
He's crazy.
But the guy,
the guy thought he was going to go kind
of like knock them around a bit and make
them look stupid,
but it was taking them long.
We should snope stack because I don't
even know if that's true.
Uh,
you know,
man kills man and Kerr.
Homeless man in Karate Academy now feel
racist for assuming he's homeless.
I don't know if that was the story.
Always was guys black and crazy.
It's probably homeless in Karate
Academy.
Snopes.
Let's see.
Karate instructor on official Dot Com.
Murder of mentally challenged,
man.
Yeah.
It seems like it really happened man.
But I mean those face stomps,
like what kind of human being does that
Kinda gotten the kind of guy who gets a
buzz cut and grows a mustache and he
works in a karate school.
Do you know what I mean?
Like that guy seems like,
not that you can't be crazy and be all
those things but doesn't seem like it
goes a little put together.
Well,
the guy who was the main guy was a
marine.
He's a karate instructor and uh,
he let his,
uh,
his student who fought this guy and the
student allegedly actually killed this
guy is the real,
the real life Cobra Pies for federal
real evil karate teacher.
Yeah.
But there's a thing,
man,
that people do.
Um,
there's a video,
Brian,
if you want to pull it up.
Well actually we probably shouldn't see
someone getting killed right up.
I mean it's online,
but it's
really,
it's,
it's a tough one to watch even.
Well that's a,
he was up for assault in the 18th of the
month on an unregulated charge.
Wow.
So I don't know what the fuck I'm
thinking if it's true.
You think with that kind of evidence,
should that guy die?
Okay.
This is stupid man.
They don't know what the fuck they're
talking about.
Hold on a second.
This is one of the things it says
sources in the medical and law
enforcement community.
The tech community tell us that indeed
the victim must have died.
The snoring at the end,
a so called agonal,
agonal breathing and assign have massive
brain damage and impending death.
That's just not true.
It isn't true.
When you get knocked out,
you snore.
That's whoever said that has never seen
someone get knocked the fuck out.
When people get knocked out,
they have that horrible snoring.
It happens all the time.
That's really scary.
Shit.
Scary Shit.
First Time I saw it,
I was 16.
I saw so many laid out just it doesn't
mean they're going to die.
That's not true at all.
So whoever wrote the store,
I don't believe him.
This guy should come out and do a show
before.
Just comes to you as like a diagonal
face to face or just get the foot
footprint.
It's still,
it's all.
I'm a VIP.
There's a video of it and there's all
these stories of it,
but none of them substantiate any like
legal stuff.
I guess you'd have to look into it deep
enough,
but apparently this shit was a long time
ago.
It looked like it was a long time based
on the theory that if he did die,
do you think that guy deserves to die?
The guy who did it,
the guy who died deserves to die early,
go killed the guy killed them.
Well,
with that kind of evidence,
like it's clearly from that.
It's clear that they were fighting.
I don't know what the conversation was
that lead that guy to be fighting that
guy.
I don't know if he said,
I'm going to come in and fight to the
death.
I don't know what I'm saying.
You know what I'm saying?
It didn't seem like that kind of a dark
underground like cooma taste situations
place in Des Moines,
Iowa.
It was a think it was in somewhere in
Georgia,
but anyway,
the guy was a schizophrenic,
so it really doesn't matter what he
said.
He's crazy.
I mean that's what happened in Virginia.
December 13th,
1984 and he's obviously crazy.
That's the thing.
He walks in,
you're like,
this guy's a.
and you could have,
you see that guy literally also could
have hugged him and that would have
ended the situation.
You know what I mean?
There's the thing that happens in
martial arts schools though,
where if you're running a martial arts
school,
crazy people will show up and they'll
start like,
they'll start shit.
I've seen it.
I've seen it firsthand.
I've seen it at my taekwondo school.
He would mind,
my instructor would take guys like that,
that would come into schools and he
would make them spar with black belts
and put them just like,
you know,
he go,
okay,
so you have to fight you a pretty good
guy,
right?
Uh,
we're gonna do some sparring here.
Okay.
Um,
you have your gear,
we have gift for you.
Do you have you again?
And he would like lower these guys in
because they would come to school and
they would go,
you all false master,
you all false master.
You don't truly know martial arts.
And you know,
they try to reason them.
Listen sir,
you know,
you can,
uh,
was the Blue Tang clan class,
but you can't yell things out like
people.
There's people that will come in that
have real mental issues and they can be
dangerous.
You know,
they also could be martial arts trained
too.
There's a lot of people that just
learned how to throw kicks and punches
from friends.
Like like if you teach an athletic
person how to deliver a good straight
punch and just show them the mechanics
of it and they practice on a heavy bag,
they'll can fuck you up if they hit.
You don't really have to be really well
trained and disciplined and so there's a
lot of people that have martial arts
abilities like the ability to punch you
really hard in the face,
but they don't really know how to fight.
They don't.
They've never been formally trained,
but they might charge you and punch you
in the face and they can be really
dangerous.
So if you're in a sort of a scenario
like that,
a lot of times these martial arts
instructors are forced to defend
themselves against these crazy people.
That didn't seem like that didn't seem
like that in this video and this video,
it seemed like they lured the guy in,
set them up,
beat the shit out of him to.
The saddest part is at one point during
like when they're just kind of like,
it almost seems like slap boxing.
The homeless guy stops me.
He goes,
your good,
your good.
Yeah.
It's kind of a fucked up video.
Any.
And he does.
He starts saying don't stop.
At one point he does tell him to stop
and then it just stopped and spit on him
while he's down.
It's gross.
I don't know if the guy died,
but if the guy did die.
Yeah,
that's basically murder.
I mean it's like perfect example.
What we said is where would that
murderous rage come out?
Would it come out if someone was trying
to kill your mom,
you probably would probably would come
out,
but this guy wasn't in that scenario.
This guy was like,
the guy was saying don't like he was
saying stop.
He'd given up like a healthy person
backs away at that point.
It's like it's merciless.
It's just complete like drilling.
I think I was so offended somehow,
but I wonder if they just got away with
shit like that and this was the only one
that people saw.
Like a wonder if this had happened more
than once because like if a guy's
willing to be the guy to death like that
and then dispose of a body and this is
the only piece of evidence that some
schizophrenia guy was murdered like
that.
Motherfuckers probably killed a bunch of
people before and he's a marine.
That's the other thing.
We don't know what kind of action he
saw.
You know,
if you,
if you have,
you know,
you're serving your country and you're
used to killing people on a regular
basis,
then you come back home and some fucking
crazy skitzo guy wants to come into
karate school and talk shit.
Yeah,
you'll get a guy killed him.
Like why not?
You've been telling people for years in
the eighties.
That was like how they yell.
Previewed like karate schools.
Like how many homeless guys if you
killed three homeless guys and counting.
I was a part of many challenge matches
where people showed up at the school and
then I got to watch them fight friends.
I,
I fought dudes that just showed up at
the school.
That was a super common thing,
but you can more or less with that.
Well,
we took them to deliver a couple.
Really?
Oh yeah.
We took a lot of those guys to the
hospital.
After we beat them up,
we'd bring them to the hospital after
they spark,
but easily could have happened
to me.
I mean I was good,
but there's a lot of good guys that came
into.
There were guys that had,
they had talent.
There's a lot of fight where you put on
gloves.
Depends.
Depends on what they said.
A lot of it was bare knuckle.
Really?
Yeah.
Because you,
you never know like what they wanted to
prove.
You know what is.
I've never,
and I've never been good at it.
Even back in school when it was the meet
me at the library,
I'd throw a punch then.
See I say that because I was like,
let's say if I got to think about till
three,
I probably won't show.
Like I'll probably chicken out like
later.
Like I'm angry now.
Let's just do it.
Let's get into it.
That's probably the
best way to get everything broken up and
keep it from being like something that
no teachers or adults know about.
The problem is if you go on a field,
meet me in the field and it's like
children,
someone can get killed.
Yeah.
The Lord of the flies.
I had to do that a few times.
It's with bullies and it always sucked,
but always it turned out me beating them
up.
So it was great.
What kind of bullies did you beat up?
High.
One was all girl.
One is now a one is now a cop and the
other guy thinks is dead.
Most of them,
most of the guys who talk the most shit
though,
just never had to really be with
somebody like stepping up to it.
Yeah.
When you're a kid,
everyone's Kinda.
I mean I bought into it too.
That's why I said,
but whatever it was instilled in me by
my dad and step up was like very much
like get it going while you're angry.
You know what I mean?
Like don't,
don't wait for it.
And that's why,
uh,
what I was going to ask when they'd come
in and they'd say like,
you know,
Rogan,
go teach this punk or lesson,
like,
like what was going on,
he'd
get nervous as fuck.
But the idea behind it was my instructor
was training a bunch of people for
National Tournament's.
So the idea was like,
these guys can hang with you,
you're a national level competitor and
this is a good thing to experience
because it's very dangerous.
So you're going to be able to,
you're going to have to perform under
some very real pressure,
like people just swinging at your face
and you know,
you're,
you're dancing around inside this closed
area looking to knock each other out.
And it happened a lot.
It happened,
I mean,
not a lot,
but it happened every three,
four months over the course of like
seven years that I was there,
every three or four months,
some guy from another school would come
into town and would want to show people
up.
We'd like,
you want to show everybody how much
better his style was and people would
duke it out.
It was,
it was crazy.
When you stop and think about it,
this is all pre UFC and there was a lot
of delusional people too.
There was a lot of people that thought
their martial art literally could not be
beaten,
but they did a certain type of wing
Chung and if they could go to a
taekwondo school and spa,
they would just run through people.
That would be no way they could stop
them.
Did you get half off your monthly dues
if he won the fight?
I didn't.
I didn't pay after a certain amount of
time.
I taught so three homeless people.
Even when I was a kid,
I started out when I was really young.
I was like,
when I was 15 I was completely dedicated
and I was there every day so they would
give me things to do.
They would give me like a clean things
or teach classes.
I taught a lot of private lessons,
like the people that are first starting
out,
you have to learn in a private lesson
for them and since I advanced
really quickly and I'd spent so much
time there,
I was pretty good at breaking down the
technical aspects of like certain moves.
You know,
it's funny and pardon the,
the hand job here,
but I think you're a fantastic comedian.
Super funny and you have such the origin
story of a guy who would not be good,
but yet I know a few people like that to
have people that are very like strict
and life about certain things.
Mike Vecchione hilarious comedian
standing is like a very like regimented
guy.
Grew up football.
He was good at it.
He excelled wrestling.
Went to Penn state wrestling there,
you know,
and then but hilarious comedian,
but it usually,
it doesn't breed the funny guy.
Yeah.
I think the introvert or the or the,
you know,
the weird kind of like social awkward
guy or the class clown type goes onto
that.
But it's usually someone,
someone's like a strict,
like,
you know,
usually that story becomes like,
I have four kids,
they all wear dockers and fucking
sweaters.
No one says fucking,
but I'm not like a,
I'm not strict.
I just get into things.
I'm just very motivated.
Like I'm a more like,
I wouldn't say I'm disciplined as much
as I get more obsessed,
you know,
discipline and things that I'm obsessed
about.
But I'm not like a strict person.
And then the other way,
like I'm not,
I'm just saying usually the comics who
like a guy who's in shape and doing
comedy and like cares about that and
cares about his health just tends to not
always be.
It's usually a guy,
it's like,
you know,
some fucking,
some pig the other day,
you know,
this fat broad because you know,
at 165 pounds you slob,
you know,
just being like that.
And you're like,
who's relating to this?
Right.
And you definitely transcend that.
But I mean that's what I'm saying.
It's weird that a,
I don't think that always happens.
I think it's more of an odd thing.
I think for the God's sake,
you know,
so I was getting,
it's when all,
all of your um,
like flaws kind of become your virtues
and comedy,
you know,
so the narrowed who got beat up and now
he's telling us stories about getting
beaten up and now girls will fuck them
because he knows how to tell a funny.
Do you know what I mean?
That's usually the origin story.
Yeah.
But it doesn't have to be.
So that's the cool thing about comedy is
there's so many versions,
you know,
like black guys have always had that
thing where they're allowed to dress up
really cool on stage where gold chains
and crazy leather outfits like remember
Eddie Murphy and yet lyricists and.
But it's the entire difference of black
comedy and white comedy if you're gonna
take by those circuits.
I said there's definitely comics that
bridge both worlds,
but the difference in is like white
mainstream comedy is very self
deprecating.
You know,
it's like my little Dick fat guy,
bald,
whatever it is.
And black is rare.
Like,
so I'm slinging the Dick,
right?
And it's just like,
I mean fucking a stool at a black comedy
club is probably owed a lot of money in
civil court to just like been fucked
here just off the side stages.
There's a bunch of like broken up stools
from a,
from gang rapings.
I mean there's so like.
But when I would watch,
I grew up like a big fan of comedy and
watching like one that in the eighties
and I would watch two
to getting to where def jam became the
thing.
I loved all that too.
I just didn't even know.
I almost didn't even notice the
difference that comedy taken a turn.
So like you know,
how good yard [inaudible] and how big
your Dick is.
Well it's comedy can be anything,
man.
It's just got to be funny.
That's what people don't understand.
Like if anybody wants to say that.
Like I've heard people say this,
this is like a social justice warrior
thing.
They say that real comedy always punches
up meaning like get it,
get at the bad person that's above you,
dominating you.
The boss,
the president pushes up and you know,
you don't pick on any people that are
below you,
but the reality is sometimes punching
down it's fucking hilarious.
Sure.
It's not,
it's not always,
but it's about what is the subject
matter,
like what it like.
You could like,
I remember Louis Ck doing a bit about
how his kid is a fucking asshole.
Sure.
And it was really fucking funny because
first of all,
you knew he wasn't serious.
It was.
I mean he was talking about his kid,
like in a frustrated way about a kid.
Just being a kid.
I'm sure he loves his kid.
Like he loves life itself,
but because he's,
he's punching down,
he's making.
He's like shitting on his kid for being
an asshole.
Sure,
sure.
And it's hilarious.
It's like there's no rules,
there's no rules like a guy has to be
self deprecating.
The guy saying,
so I'm slinging that Dick,
right?
I'm given that deck.
You know when you give,
giving that good tick and you feel that
as whole reverberating off your ball
sack every time you come down home with
little loop the loop,
you can be crying,
laughing,
listening to that,
crying,
laughing or you could be crying,
laughing,
listening to a guy who talks about it.
We can never get laid.
The variable in those things is just,
is it funny or is it not funny?
That's the important variable.
We.
Me and my buddy washed nick Nikennon
special.
You want to have fun man.
Get stoned and just watching nick cannon
special.
It's just if you like.
I love watching just ridiculously
horrible comedy.
It's my favorite thing in the world.
Good and just watching the Canon by an
hour of television so he can slowly but
surely peel down from a Tuxedo to a tank
top is one of the first week as a
backdrop.
That's just a million light bulbs,
so when he moves it's going to give you
a fucking seizure.
And his jokes,
we're all like,
you know,
you meet a girl up in a club and you're
all like splatoon just noises.
And then apparently Brian,
Gary was texting that night,
like live tweeting or whatever,
but she goes,
I told you my baby was funny.
Oh my God,
I love that.
If you want to watch a show that just
bring joy to your life.
Have you ever heard of Bill Bellamy's
who got jokes?
Oh,
well,
just take a weekend and really dig into
it because it's A.
I don't think I have it in me.
It's a comedy.
Yeah.
You don't like watching bad comedy?
No.
This is.
It's on tv one,
which is a black TV network.
I didn't know that existed.
Yeah,
it's called TV One and Bill Bellamy
hosted a isn't on top.
No,
it's done now I think to Tommy from
Martin,
but it airs on marathons,
on this network.
Tommy from Martin is the column,
the Pope of comedy.
He sits on the throne and judges as
three comics come out and they do.
The first round is just,
they're set in front of an audience and
there's three people from the audience
picked at random to be the judges where
they give a score from one to five,
five being the best,
one being the worst.
Everyone gets a five.
And if you give someone a for the
audience loses their shit,
they get very mad at you.
That's around one.
The comedy is always got awful.
And then,
uh,
it unprepared,
usually it looks like the,
these guys,
another we're going to do a TV show that
day and uh,
and then round two,
they come out and they do some kind of
challenge that you don't under which
they have a heckler in the audience or
somebody comes out like actually
actually a producer and hit you in the
face with a pie and you got to keep
going.
And then they judge you score from one
to five and it's just horrible,
horrible comedy.
But it makes me laugh.
Like,
why does that make you laugh?
Just because it works.
I'm amazed by I'm very interested and
that there's actually a science to
comedy.
Don't you find that interesting?
There's like actual science,
so you could just say the right words.
Have you ever seen a comedy hypnotist
now?
Never seen one of those guys.
Dude,
you got to see a comedy hypnotist.
If you get a chance,
a real ones,
I just assume it's fake.
You know,
not fake at all.
There's something that really stupid
people are susceptible to that you're
not susceptible to.
There's someone can like say some things
to you onstage,
snap their finger and some people
literally go into a trance.
Sure they can do it.
Those people will laugh at anything to
they're dumb as fuck to.
I think what the reality of this world
is that there's people that are.
Their brains don't work so good,
they just don't,
and there's not a goddamn thing you can
do about it.
It's not about education.
It's not about how much information you
give them.
It's not about the environment they're
in.
They have nine volt brains.
No,
I know.
And like the funniest to give the
audience.
The audience has never communally stood
up to someone who was like,
that's hacky.
Like the audience never says that.
It's always being judged by other
comments.
Say this is in general,
like when there's a hacky comic on
stage,
usually he's destroying it depends on
where you're at,
right?
I mean if you're in la or New York,
those guys could he beat and shit
possibly.
But forums like this where comics and
people get to talk and like there's so
much insight information out now.
I think it kind of weeds through that
happened and now I think the audiences
are a little smarter in some circles,
but they have to be fans.
Like if you.
Do you remember going to see comedy when
you first started to like go to open mic
nights.
See guys that you thought were really
funny and then like a year later you
fucking couldn't even be in the room and
they're on stage.
Oh,
I mean the people I worshiped when I
started,
I was like,
just the way he kills,
you know,
like I got
to do a joke where I open up and say dj
put that shit on one more time because
everyone had to have one of those.
I used to get down to the underwear on
stage,
used to get down to my underwear posing
to the 2001 theme.
Oh God.
And then one day no one left.
I didn't do ever again.
I went to see this guy when I was in a.
When I was in Boston before I did stand
up,
I went to see this,
a comedy at a play it again,
Sam's.
It was like this movie house that had
stand up in the basement and this guy
did these like fake adlibs and I knew
they were fake while it's happening.
I didn't understand comedy be but he
pointed to me and he goes,
and this guy is over here saying this,
but I didn't say anything.
I don't remember what it was,
but I remember like,
he's like,
what?
I couldn't believe that he was
pretending that there was some sort of a
weird interaction.
We asked for the rest of the audience
and so I realized that this guy was just
bullshitting and this is kind of this
fake dance.
And then as I got to know him,
I kept seeing them over and over and
over again.
He was doing the same thing.
Every time he would,
he would set this bit up,
he would point to a guy in the audience
and he's like this.
He would say the same thing.
Like he never,
he had his fake adlibs with the crowd.
There was no variation.
So if you saw him more than once the act
was done like the,
the,
the veil had been lifted.
It doesn't bring any joy to watch.
Like that level of shitty comedy like
happened.
No,
it makes me sad.
It makes me laugh.
So I,
I used to any show when it comes,
I just can't believe nothing when you
watch somebody either on television and
their first joke is,
now I know what you guys are thinking.
Actually,
I had a guy open for me one time on the
road where,
uh,
he had a joke.
I forget what it even was it about,
but whatever it was,
the crowd never laughed in the middle of
it.
And he goes,
uh,
so my family used to run a funeral home.
He goes,
now you guys laugh.
But he goes into his job,
but no one,
no one laughed at that.
But every time he goes,
now you guys laugh.
But I had never.
That's always funny.
The now,
uh,
I know what you're thinking,
you see me and I'm like,
it happens a lot.
People like it.
I feel you should never,
and a lot of us do,
but you should never get on television
with your first ever set,
you know,
when you go on,
when you go on the road and me,
you know,
as a,
uh,
when I,
when I go on the road and someone opens
for me,
I'm generally getting somebody doing
their first set.
You remember that.
Like when every time he got on stage it
was the introduction.
So my name is Jay and I blah,
blah blah,
you know,
it's like first day girl comedy.
So I'm so and so and I'm a total slot
and I sex with my friends and it's just
like that.
But that first set makes it on tv a lot.
Now [inaudible],
there's so many forums.
Yeah,
but that's just life.
You just kind of move on,
just deal with it.
It's probably not good to have your
first set,
but if you've been doing standup for 10
years or whatever it is,
when you get your first set on tv,
six years just fuckin accepted sucks
except that it sucks and move on,
you know,
and you won't know.
It sucks until you see it.
You gotta watch it on TV like later in
your career when you're better and you'd
go.
But yeah,
I'm,
I'm saying I'm surprised that the behind
the scenes don't catch up to like,
like to see like there's no like,
uh,
they don't take any cues from the actual
community of comedy itself.
Do you know what I mean?
They're like,
this guy's been doing comedy for five
months.
Like of course he should be on
letterman.
You know what I mean?
The behind the scenes,
people know they're always looking for
someone to come along to prodigy.
That figures it out after four months.
So weird.
But I don't know if they do that person
any favors though.
They definitely don't.
They don't give a fuck though.
All they care about is what can they
sell.
Just like the reality show,
as I,
if you've noticed,
if you've watched the video of moved
into a new chair,
ladies and gentlemen,
I don't know if this one's going to make
it and I don't know,
but the other thing is better than no
back things better.
Um,
but it's,
you know,
they just sell you,
you know?
Sure.
If they can sell the hook is you
Olympians in Stanford,
five months,
they're not going to protect you.
They're not going to go up that big Jay.
He's got potential for the future.
Let's not put it.
Five month old comedy set.
No the fuck you get on TV.
Who gives a shit sink or swim as many
more people they have to pay attention
to.
They don't give a fuck.
I'll look.
I'm sure the fucking.
What's it?
The hunger games.
People were pretty thrilled that j dot
snatches out there.
That's huge for them.
Just drew a whole new audience to that
show because I don't know how those two
are connected,
but we're talking about someone being
hacked now.
Someone who was talking about.
I thought you were saying about selling
things like the company.
I was saying that companies that don't
care,
like the movie companies don't care that
she gets like exposed.
You know what I mean?
Is it does give them a good job.
They don't protect her.
I'm saying they don't.
They don't come out.
They would have protected her.
I'm sure they probably wouldn't have let
it be released but it.
But it's to their benefit now that it
is.
I kind of guess so.
Yeah.
But it's a different thing than I had in
my mind.
I was like,
did it have nothing to do with it?
I'm like,
no.
There was a connection in my mind.
There was something there I guess.
I guess I've only seen the first one now
I want to watch more after seeing her
naked.
Right.
Which is good for the company.
So the movie company,
even though it's like they pay her and
she's like,
you know,
she has a relationship with them.
They don't give a fuck if something to
her detriment builds up their movie.
Yeah,
I could see that probably.
probably after it's over there,
like they probably would have protected
her from getting out.
But once it's out like hey look,
in the long run we're going to do bro.
She looks great.
Sat around the office and yeah,
it's true being the only way you're ever
going to get protected as a comic
because if you have a manager and the
manager will say,
listen Jane,
you know,
let's keep hitting the clubs and you
know,
wait a year,
wait,
wait a couple of years,
we'll just work.
Where's that manager?
Jeff Salzman.
Yeah,
my guy.
it's hard.
You've got to develop comedians.
Like you got to treat them as like a
longterm project.
You can't like move people into a house
before you can put a roof on it and he
can't pretend it's done.
What's not done.
And when you see a young guy that's got
potential,
I mean everybody that we've ever met,
they go through periods like you were
talking about your black comedy period.
Sure.
You know,
people go through these weird phases
where they're trying to find themselves
as,
I hate to use the word,
but artists find myself as an artist
man.
And uh,
but the thing is if there's a video of
you have five months in and then it's
terrible,
but there's a way better video two years
later.
Well,
if someone watches both,
they go out.
Jay got better,
you know,
it's just,
there's nothing wrong.
Oh,
I did bet.
Comicview thrice three times.
Really?
Yeah.
So I mean,
like who was hosting the first one ever
was lester barry who was a black circuit
comic for the very religious.
Nice.
The second time I did it was Arnez J in
Miami.
And the third time third time was funny
because I said by this point I go,
I'm not doing comic view ever again.
Like I just,
I've written that one off,
I'm not doing it.
It's always an awkward situation when I
go there too.
Why?
Because I'm the only white guy,
the production is white and they put
some weird responsibility on me to be
like the den mother of the comics,
so I've like smoked cigarettes and I'd
go outside,
I'm going to go outside and smoke a
cigarette.
She goes,
okay,
wait a second.
He was everyone Jay's going to smoke if
you want to smoke,
go out now with him and everyone's got
to be back in here in 15 minutes.
And then she tried to get me all of
their food tickets so I'd be responsible
for them.
It was very bizarre.
Just because you're white.
Yeah,
I mean I assume so.
That said,
a lot of the black comics will do things
like I'm going to go out and smoke and
then go like,
you know,
fuck a chick for five hours trying to
cut back 15 minutes before the show
starts.
So that did happen.
Well,
what they want you to do is just hang
out all day waiting for the show to
start.
Oh,
they put you there at nine in the
morning until night.
I went on at midnight.
What?
Yeah,
because they just don't want this
wrangle.
Everybody acts.
They don't believe anyone.
No,
no belief.
They're going to stay there.
They've done entire shows about how
happy they are.
Like they'll do a show where the same
joke gets repeated by different
comedians.
Well yeah,
and so I went and did it.
Kevin Hart ended up hosting I think one
of the last ever seasons,
but it was called one mic stand and
where something like that I think is
what it's called,
one mic stand,
but it wasn't called comic view and
Kevin called me and asked me if I wanted
to do it or if I would do it.
And I said,
yeah,
but I don't want to do comic view
anymore.
He goes,
it's not comic view.
It's different.
They're flying people out now.
They're doing it all right.
And set it up good.
And it was a.
When I signed the contract,
gets comic presents,
one mic stand.
They gave us a big speech before we
taped anything and the guy was like,
we're changing comic fuel.
It's going to be different.
And the guys specifically said no more
stool humping and dj hit it and pulling
out fake teeth.
And uh,
I mean we weren't three comics in before
the guy was wearing fake teeth and
fucking a stool.
I mean not even by the way,
when he's giving this speech to it,
these same guys who were getting ready
to fuck stools and put in fake teeth are
doing like,
you know,
like staring at him,
give the speech and like nodding their
heads like a Pachino speech in any given
Sunday.
It's like an emotional,
powerful speech.
How we're changing comic view now.
And then they went and they were like,
yeah,
let's go out there and show the world
something.
And then two minutes later you're like,
Dj put that Shit back on that bitch with
fake teeth to this one was black
surrogates made for some great,
great,
great stories.
I had a guy one time,
this is true story.
Kevin used to host a club in Atlantic
city,
Kevin Hart called sweet cheeks,
sweet,
violent.
It was like a pimps and players ball.
No bullshit.
It was like everyone was wearing zoot
suits and shit.
And bringing like three chicks a piece
and they were all dressed up fancy,
but they interrupt dancing to do a
comedy show in the middle of the fucking
night.
Like two,
3:00
in the morning.
Yeah.
And I,
I was hosting at one time for Kev,
you couldn't do it.
And they hated me.
They absolutely didn't like me at all
and I was going to bring the comic on
stage and I go like,
all right,
but I'm gonna bring up next to go what's
your name?
And he goes,
uh,
ignorant Nigga.
And I was like,
dude,
don't make me say that please.
And he's like,
that's my name as my stage name.
And I kept,
I begged him to let me call him by his
regular name and I go,
it's not going to go good if I said.
He goes,
it's fine man.
I'll explain.
It's my name.
You know,
he set you up?
Yeah.
When are you going on stage?
He goes,
you're going to let that white boy call
me.
And I left.
I just left the show.
I drove off.
Yeah.
That was like,
it was a dangerous place.
The bouncer outside was a bounty hunter
also,
so he would run ids.
Everybody that walked in,
he'd get five people in light on
warrants.
Wow,
that's crazy.
He was a bounty hunter and an ID
checker.
Yeah.
That's like fishing in a fucking
swimming pool.
That's so not fair.
That seems like a deer in a stock pond.
You know what I mean?
It just seems really fucked up a night
club and it was just like an a pimps and
players nightclub.
Yeah,
they threw the chicken wings at me one
time.
Wow.
It was a.
and I think I.
Yeah,
I think I was doing that joke where I
was getting down to my underwear.
Who the fuck wants them to do comedy at
2:00
in the morning and a place where they
have dancing.
They do.
I used to do these ski trips shows that
were like black ski trips and black
people don't even ski at all.
They don't.
They go and they,
they took a bus thing to go to this
hotel and they'd all just like,
fuck each other fucking drink,
you know,
green alcohol and a green alcohol,
just like Tang arrays and the drinks
were always great.
Like thug passion streaks.
Yeah.
And I go up there and open someone's
already headline for these black ski
trips and they just fucking hated it.
Wanted no parts of the comedy show.
I never understand why they force comedy
into places where it doesn't need to be
at all.
Well,
people make money,
you know,
I'm sure Kevin Hart got a nice piece by
navy,
I mean was,
he was very young.
We were like brand new in comedy,
but I mean if somebody offers it and
you're like,
yeah,
we can do a show there.
Fuck it.
Yeah.
I mean the bar shows that New York
that's become such a thing.
Bar shows are shows and I go to them
with this,
you know,
this expectation.
What blows my mind about I think bar
shows or a cool thing to have as far as
like open mics.
Basically.
Little produce shows you can get people
on,
but like I'll hear my friends,
you know,
or younger comics who I know and I'll be
like,
where are you at tonight?
And he goes,
so and so I go,
oh,
well do this other thing with me.
Like don't go to that bullshit bar show.
And it's like,
I've been booked this for three months.
Like whoa.
Yeah,
they call you.
It's like you want to do my bar show
it's batch when it sees bet 25 people,
uh,
you know,
he's getting a drink ticket or half
price off drinks and it's on Tuesday at
9:00
PM,
somewhere in nowhere fucking Brooklyn.
And then it's like,
oh yeah,
I guess I can do it.
And it's like,
you know,
okay.
So I'm looking at like,
I have my book open here,
like December,
like May,
like they really booked this things far
out.
Is that just because there's so many
comics in New York?
It is.
I think it's a lot of it becomes like
people just getting their friends on his
ship probably find the gas because he's,
a lot of these shows have become like
legit to some degree.
Well if it's a good show,
well run.
It's very valuable to comedians.
Sure.
I gave you,
you know,
you go to Wednesday night comedy juice,
the Improv,
so he's going to be packed.
It's a great place to work out material.
Like that becomes the.
Yeah.
But you know what I'm saying?
Sure.
So shows like that become valuable and
then little side gigs like was a place
you were talking about three clubs and
what does it mean?
Clubs?
Yeah,
I mean like all these kinds of bars
says.
But the like with the old red rocks has
one now that's,
that's like in the corner.
But the problem is New York is like a
billion times more bar shows in la.
So like all the local comics in La,
they will get that one shitty bar show,
but it's like,
yeah,
it's like a month away when they get it.
Like how many rooms are there all told
in New York?
If you had to guests,
you live in Manhattan.
Yeah.
How many rooms do you think comedy
standup rooms or in the,
in the actual clubs,
we could run through them.
Really a stay at New York comic strip
seller,
Gotham,
the stand stand.
Um,
Caroline's Caroline's.
Then there's a Greenwich Village Comedy
Club,
New York Comedy Club,
Broadway Comedy Club,
New York comedy clubs.
Still around.
Just bought my new guy danger fields who
are 10.
Um,
there is a lol comedy club in Times
Square.
Lol.
Yeah.
And then there's like places there's
like,
and then like some room show there every
week times square,
lol,
lol.
I'm good dude.
I'm not fucking with them.
Uh,
11 were at 11 and then there's.
And then there's like,
oh,
Eastville comedy club 13.
I think.
Yeah,
I mean it's really,
it's pretty nuts.
Yeah.
So that's the major clubs.
It's really awesome.
Did we say God didn't take them?
So that's,
uh,
that's the major clubs.
Yeah.
And then on top of that you got how many
bar shows?
Yeah.
Do you
think in the city or around the.
Even the boroughs in the city?
Just in the city,
just in Manhattan,
I mean there's got to be fucking 10 a
night fight against at least.
At least.
That's crazy.
It's also like the people
that live in New York and go to New
York,
there are more into like plays and live
performances that I think like the west
coast is.
Well,
if you're a young person or any person
who's got free time at night and you're
looking for some entertainment,
it's one of the best place in the world
and go,
you can go to the seller.
If you can go to caroline's and you can
see live comedy in New York every night
of the week.
You can see killers.
You could see,
you know,
a pto and ck and all these different
people show up at clubs.
I mean,
it's one of the best places in the world
to go out and see live comedy.
Oh,
New York.
Yeah.
Fantastic.
Just to go out.
I mean,
that's what people,
if they've never been in New York
before,
they're like,
there's so many restaurants and
somebody.
This is somebody that it's fucking mad
scene.
I drove by the laugh factory last night
out here and it was like the line was
like wrapped around the building.
That's Jamie doesn't let people in.
He wants that line to be wrapped around
the building.
He doesn't just like let people in.
He makes you stay outside so it looks
like a line out there.
We're signing up for tomorrow.
Those a lot of them was like the open
mic nights,
like they have to open mic nights.
They make people sit out there from 9:00
in the morning,
whatever the fuck the sign up time is
and they have to wait in line until they
get picked and then they go on next
week.
They don't even go on that week.
The wait in line all day and they go on
the next week.
Why exactly.
We've been.
We've been rallying against this next
time I a control.
Exactly.
It's a ridiculous idea that he has that
in doing so he makes the club more
special because it was always a big
line.
It's tough to get in,
put your thumb on people that could
eventually like,
you know,
like say like,
this is my home,
this is the club that showed me the
love.
Like why?
Yeah,
I never got that.
That same evil shit that makes producers
put someone on a reality show and then
try to own everything about them for the
next 10 years or whatever the fuck it
is.
It's the same thing.
It's like greedy thing that people do
out here,
this weird,
creepy fucking behavior where the people
that are coming up,
I'm not respected as potential equals
and if they do somehow another make it
through.
It's never through their own merit.
It's because of the good nature and
your,
you know,
your generosity.
That's led them to this position of
being a good a showbiz person.
I find it weird with any comedy club
that doesn't have comics hanging out at
it and like they want people to hang out
like comp comedians to hang out like
that place.
The laugh factory.
That's the one thing that I've always
heard is like,
no,
they don't let you hang out there.
There's one getting to hang out there,
it's there.
I know.
I think that that's only to a certain
group of,
you know,
the big guys,
but the average comic is what that
always tells me that
I did a club on the road one time where
there was a young comics hanging out.
So I was like,
uh,
I talked to them for a little while and
I was like,
you know,
if you guys want to go on like,
you can put you guys on each one do like
seven minutes or something,
go for it.
And they told me and I confirmed with
the club that they go,
Oh,
now the club doesn't do guest spots at
all.
Like at all.
I got thought it's kind of up to the
isn't up to like the headliner if he
like,
doesn't care,
like it was fine.
They go now that's
just like our policy don't do it.
I go and I told him when I talked to the
manager guy,
I was like,
why would you discourage comics from
hanging out?
It's very like,
you know what I mean?
It doesn't make,
it's not a friendly environment.
Well Wendy Curtis,
you know,
it's kind of things you work those
shitty open mic show.
So eventually maybe they'll give you a
shot at like hosting a weekend or you
know,
doing something like that guest spots.
Do you know Wendy from comedy works in
Denver?
I know who she is.
Yeah.
She,
uh,
she had a great way of describing it.
She goes,
why would you sell widgets and not have
like a widget development team?
Like why wouldn't you,
if you want to sell other people's
widgets,
you can make your own inhouse widgets.
Like what are you doing when you're
running a comedy club?
You're not develop any local talent.
You don't develop any of it.
Like it's one of the things like they
were moving improv's into town and she
was saying like,
what are you guys going to do for like
developing local talent?
And they're like,
nothing.
She was like,
what?
Like that's alien.
Like she's developed a bunch of
comedians out of that club and she has
like a whole system of taking people
from MCS to relax to headliners.
Like it's really well thought out,
really like conscientious system of
helping these artists,
you know,
sometimes they have their babies,
but when people come to New York yet
it's always a two coin flip.
If someone's like what city?
You're from Miami.
Like,
oh,
what was your home club like?
Oh,
the owner.
There was a piece of shit.
Treat me like an asshole.
Would you say about babies?
Some of them are babies,
no.
What'd you say?
Should I say babies?
But I don't know.
Because you were saying that people
complain about the sale when someone
comes to the to like move to New York
from their home club,
you know,
where they started.
It's a coin flip.
Whether they're going to say it was a
great experience.
So you know,
they're very supportive of them.
They get behind some people,
the local clubs and then some they just
like,
there's such shitty people,
but I never understand being shitty to
like local town.
This is crazy.
People in clubs,
you know,
crazy people on dance clubs,
crazy people tends to be a certain
personality type here.
You've got to be a hardcore motherfucker
to own a bar,
you know,
and to own a comedy club and just want
to deal with comedians all the time.
You got to be either someone who loves
comedy or an insane person.
Do you get frustrated when,
uh,
when people that are around comedy
enough,
even if it doesn't make sense in their
life,
they're like,
I'm going to try and they started doing
open mics or do you like,
go for it?
What do you mean?
Do you get like,
I know this club owners in New York,
even that just fucking start doing
comedy after owning the club for like
three years,
where like,
I'm doing it,
I'm going to give it a shot.
But who knows,
maybe there'll be good.
They hired bookers and the booker start
trying to do Qa.
It's like very weird.
Well,
eleanor,
eleanor Kerrigan,
she was a waitress at the comedy store
forever.
I knew her as a waitress for more than
10 years now.
She's a real professional comic.
She started like many,
many years in because she had no around
comedy.
No thought about doing it ever?
Nope.
Just got,
get another job.
One day actress.
She was an actress.
She did a lot of acting.
She was in wrestling.
She did some pro wrestling and then
somewhere along the line she just
decided,
fuck it,
I'm going to go on stage.
And she started doing standup.
Yeah,
I mean now she's a pro.
She's
funny.
I mean it's crazy.
I mean she's smart so she understands
like what's funny and what's not funny.
She knows what's happening and what's
not.
So she didn't fall in any pitfalls.
Maybe I feel the ego stroke because I
feel like when it's done,
like uh,
the current Metzker,
you know,
Kurt Kurt's never had a girlfriend that
has eventually been like,
well,
if this shit had never vocalized that,
but in my mind,
like if my chick was like,
I want to do comedy,
I'm like,
what do you think?
It's like super simple.
You think it's that easy.
You just go with like,
you know what?
I'm gonna do your stupid thing.
It looks a lot more fun than my stupid
thing.
Well it's also when they're around
comics,
they see how fun it is and they see like
how comic think and then they start
thinking like comics and same ridiculous
shit show if you're,
if you're around chick like long enough,
like she'll start seeing how you pick
things apart and make sure like if
you're around someone who's really funny
at work,
you know,
and it's like I have this boss who is a
private investigator.
Dude was hilarious.
He was just instantly hilarious.
Just would find things that were goofy
about people and start and you would
just how with this guy.
And I learned a lot like being around
him,
I started doing that too.
Like you start seeing how he would find
these patterns.
Like he was very predatory,
like the patterns that we find that
we're fucked up and people and just
attack those patterns and it's like
teaching pick it up in relationships.
People pick it up and friendships.
So you know,
Kurt is a funny dude.
I get these checks were probably around
them and they were like,
Yo,
what can fucking do this?
I see what's going on here.
I guess you could make it look
effortless maybe,
but like sort of also fun,
you know,
I mean if fun.
Sure.
Not Enjoying your life and you know,
not enjoying your job,
but you saw a guy like you having the
time of his life cracking jokes,
making shit.
God dammit.
I think I could do that.
He looks he looks way better than a
regular job.
If you're a person that has a regular
job and then someone like big Jay comes
along,
you're hanging out with them and you
watch and how he does it.
Like this fucking guy's barely working
here.
Sure.
He's just laughing about shit and
writing it down and then figuring out a
way to say it on stage in a funny way.
Fuck selling insurance.
How many people did you grow up with,
um,
before comedy that genuinely happy for
you?
Like really feel it.
What do you mean?
Like do you have like friends from
before comedy still and are like
genuinely happy for your success and
like dig.
What you do is like if,
if I have one friend from growing up
that I'm still friends with and it's
because he's the only one of my friends
that is doing what he wanted to do.
Also,
you have to have that self security
before you can like really cheap.
I'd go back to philly constantly,
barely any.
I mean I hung out with a lot of people
on it growing up.
No one comes out.
No one gives a shit.
Really.
None of them give a shit at all.
Come to your shows.
You mean once in a while one of them
will pop up,
but a lot of times they'll say they're
coming and they don't show up.
I mean,
I stopped giving a shit years ago.
I realized that all at one time because
a bunch of them did come at once and
afterwards they were like,
good job man.
So we're all going over.
It's like dollar beer night at the so
and so.
He went ahead and I'm like,
well,
hang here for a few minutes to catch up
and whatever.
They go,
the place kind of closes
in like an hour and you're like,
alright,
bye.
Fuck faces.
I guess like,
so what did you want them to spend more
time having the Dodo vary by having seen
these people in a while and I was
genuinely curious about what's going on
with them but you didn't want to go to
their spot,
but I just also,
they were very dismissive of the whole
thing,
like thanks dude.
Pretty good job.
It's just seemed to.
Didn't seem very.
Like if they would've been like,
wow dude,
this is a pretty extraordinary thing
you're doing at any point.
I'm not saying they had to say those
words,
but they showed that at all.
It makes them have to face the fact that
like,
you know,
he said he was going to be a pilot but
he's working at a fucking gas station.
Do you attribute it to jealousy or
disinterest or what do you attribute it
to?
It might be a little bit of both.
Who knows,
but I know when I first started doing it
again,
like you said,
the way you did taekwondo,
it's a heavy commitment,
especially because I started going after
the first year of just doing it in
Philly,
Keith Robinson grabbed me,
Kurt Metzger and Kevin Hart and started
taking us up to New York and I did that.
I started not being able to do all the
bullshit with my friends that we were
doing.
I wasn't part of like dollar beer night
anymore,
you know what I mean?
Or any of that shit.
So and,
but when I would come back and be like,
hey guys,
I'm doing this cool thing,
like,
come check this out.
They were just like,
Eh,
I don't care.
You know what I'm saying?
Oh No,
I'm going to go do this,
this neat show in Atlantic city or
whatever the case always went live.
When you're growing up,
there's certain people that you grow up
with because they went to school with
you and then with your friends and some
folks evolve and develop and change and
grow and some people stagnate and
actually develop problems for themselves
to distract themselves.
Like I grew up at some kids that were
really good friends and then they became
like,
one of them became a pill head.
Like he's gone.
Like I don't talk to me more.
If he called me,
I wouldn't call them back.
You know,
you could probably get ahold of me,
but he's too fucked up.
It's too fucked up.
I know his family.
I know all the disasters he's been
through.
Just said I'm not interested in
communicating,
so there's going to be people like that
in your life.
Have you had to circumstantial
friendships in comedy?
You know what I mean?
Like that.
Just like for you,
like you hung with someone for a little
while and then like,
I guess it really like the Rosa.
Did he live with me for awhile?
When he first moved to New York,
when he moved out and we were tight,
we were together every day.
We drove in together to the city and
from Queens and hung out all the time
and I just don't describe being Joseph
friends.
Like he's my buddy for sure,
but I mean I'm probably the 30th person.
He would call him if he had good news
and his life.
You know what I mean?
I'd probably hear it third hand first
and we have no beef at all.
When I see him,
we'd love to catch up and bullshit and
have a good time.
But you know what I'm saying?
Like it turns out the issue just you
need more from him.
I'm just saying I need more from him.
I didn't even call me too.
I think he's,
I think he's angry at my racism is also.
Oh,
that Anthony Kumi a thing of the day was
just so ridiculous.
He did our show and uh,
I heard you on the show.
Went on this long thing that was very
jilted lover ish in a lot of ways about
Kumi not calling.
I'm like,
fine,
it's just call him because I mean,
it also recognized that the guy's busy.
No,
he defended all these other people but
he didn't defend me.
I'm like,
oh,
come on man,
cause he didn't like talk about you
online.
Like you're,
you're upset at them.
And then there was this accusations of
racism that they also didn't discuss.
You know,
it's like,
it was,
it was.
So all of it could have been handled
better.
Watch them go on the Anthony Show.
Yeah,
I listened to it.
I mean look how that end.
It should,
he should have never.
You should never just written them off
if a guy's your friend and he's involved
in some sort of a public crisis like
Anthony was,
you know,
first of all you have to recognize
there's a tremendous amount of stress
involved in any sort of physical
altercation.
So don't expect people to behave
rationally after someone punched him.
That's one.
And then two,
don't expect people to behave rationally
after like gigantic groups of people
start calling you a racist and saying,
you know what you're doing by writing
all the is like essentially a hate
crime.
He got fired from your job.
People Rally for you to get fired from
your job.
Other people rally for you to get
rehired.
They want other people to boycott the
show and cancel Sirius xm because of
that.
There was a lot stress going on.
The idea that he's ignoring Jojo tweets.
Like fuck man.
Like what?
What?
What version of the thing did you see?
That job is a little bit selfish.
Sure.
Yeah.
And I love Joe.
He's a great guy.
That's what makes joe a really funny
comic,
is that he obsesses on things.
He thinks about things until he finds
out what's really funny about them and
then he figures out a way to do it
onstage and figures out a way to cut it
down to like a really funny joke.
He's a great comic.
Shouldn't that same sort of curiosity,
sensibility,
obsession,
all those.
The combination of things mixed together
in a stew.
You know,
sometimes I could fuck with your
personal life,
you know,
I think that's probably what happened
there.
You know,
that if,
if it was a more rational circumstance
for anthony,
more rational response by Joe,
I think they could have had a
conversation about it and work through
and I think they did kind of,
I just don't understand how joe in any
way,
shape or form had a feeling where it was
like this effect to him in some way.
I don't know how people,
I mean I had,
I had a,
I got tweets that were like a,
you know,
cancel Sirius xm standby.
And I just,
I just didn't.
Not that I don't,
I,
I did.
Uh,
I did,
uh,
Anthony [inaudible] podcast after that
and talk to I,
I,
I am,
I understand why he did what he did.
I think he should've done the way he did
it.
I think there's a better way to handle
I think he does too.
Of course he does.
But I'm saying,
but I just think like,
I don't know,
but it was just.
I agree that serious fired him.
I wish he didn't get fired.
I wouldn't have done it myself,
but I'm not blown up when they said he's
fired,
I wasn't like,
wait,
what?
Like I completely understand that the
fire,
the shit though will rain down on them.
It wasn't worth it to them.
So they fired him.
Yeah,
I understand.
It's a business call,
but
it is kind of a business call,
but it's also a business call to not do
it.
Like you have to decide like what,
what,
what helps your business giving that guy
an opportunity to express himself on the
show would have generated a tremendous
amount of ratings,
you know?
Absolutely.
And I think if he'd done it eloquently,
which I'm sure he would've,
there would've been a tremendous amount
of support for keeping them on the show.
I think his,
his argument in his assertion about the
black community has always been there's
a violence problem in the black
community.
It's not that he's racist against all
black people.
What his point has always been is that
there's a lot of folks that are not
willing to concede that there's a
violence issue and he thinks there is an
issue,
you know,
where he and I don't know what his take
on the social ramifications or the
reasons for this racial issue or there's
violence issue in the black community.
You know,
I think it's an economic thing.
And what I've always pointed to is the
Gypsies,
and in England and Ireland and who are
constantly getting involved in crime and
fighting and the bare knuckle
motherfuckers and they're white.
You know,
those type of people.
Um,
the people that live in these
economically challenging situations
where there's a lot of bad people around
them in a lot of crime and violence.
That's the atmosphere you,
you live in.
That's the soup you fucking were born
into.
And the shit's hard to deal with for
everybody.
And I think that what he did is also a
function of that form of media.
Like doing things in 140 characters.
You can express yourself very good in
140 characters.
And if you take,
even if you take something from
something you said in this podcast and
put it in 140 characters in quotes and
put it on a tweet,
it could make it look like a real piece
of Shit,
you know?
Well,
but what it really was like,
he just tweeted out what he should just
said.
Well he,
you know,
exact part,
it's a piece of plywood or no,
he should have set it on the radio.
But by then he could have gotten a way
to say it so eloquently.
I'm talking about in that moment of
fury,
you need to call a friend who's going to
go,
I know,
dude.
Right?
I know you're so right.
And then 15 minutes later when you calm
down,
you go,
of course I don't hit every black
person.
It's like he,
he vented and I said,
and he's such a guy who's used to
preaching to the choir and he forgot
that there's like regular people behind
that choir that I'm going to be like,
we're waiting to hear catch that.
Catch them like it's way easier.
Yeah.
Take your tweet and retweet it than it
is to say,
hey,
you gotta,
listen to Anthony on Sirius xm this
morning when he was going off about how
there's a violence problem in the black
community and all the crazy shit that he
screamed and yelled about.
That's one thing,
but to someone to just take those tweets
and retweet them or take them to cut and
paste them and put them in a blog
completely outside of the context of who
you are,
what your style of communicating with
has always been on the show.
The style of communicating on the show
has always been him screaming.
She's always done that,
so when he does that in a twitter form,
it's par for the course.
I mean that's what he does.
It's just when he does it on the radio,
the people that are going to be upset at
that,
they would have to listen to the whole
thing to get to that.
They would have to listen to that chunk.
Someone would have to alert them to it.
They'd have to like listen to it all
play out.
All they have to do is just hear it,
see it,
retweet it,
see it on a blog and then a bunch of
fucking outrage attached to it and all
these accusations,
but
what do you do at that point?
I mean on.
In your opinion,
do you come out in high defense of
yourself or do you just go sit back and
go?
My.
His resume kind of speaks for itself.
Like you could just look at his body of
work and notes that he's clearly not a
outwardly racist.
I mean like that.
Well,
a lot of people who want to kill those
people to his world or like
a lot of people disagree with you there.
A lot of people disagree with you.
That's a fact.
A lot of people take a lot of the things
that he said on the radio show,
cut them out of context and put it up
and say that these are more pieces of
evidence that he's racist.
I don't think he's racist.
I think he's frustrated.
I think that he liked a lot of people
that have been involved in these types
of scenarios.
You only see the person's attacking you
and you only see the group that they're,
they're attached to and if I lived in
New York and I had to deal with a lot of
bullshit on a regular basis,
I don't know how much bullshit he deals
with,
but whether it was bullshit coming from
Irish people or it's bullshit coming
from,
you know,
Asian people that are fuck with me all
the time.
I mean if you were living in a group
where there's a certain number of people
from x community that are causing a lot
of crimes,
you're always gonna have some
frustration.
You're going always going to be upset
about that.
I don't know where his head's at.
I don't,
I've never had like long,
like uncensored conversations with him
about this.
I've talked to him on the radio and I
love talking to them,
so I.
If I had to guess,
I would say no,
I don't think he's racist.
I think he's just not scared of speaking
his mind about very controversial issues
that could very easily come across cross
as racism when he's describing things
like very real statistics like crime
statistics,
like they're undeniable mean if you look
at crime statistics and the amount of
young African American men that are in
jail,
it's fucking bananas.
It's bananas representative of the
population as a whole.
Like this small amount of people that
are black and then the large amount of
black guys that are in jail.
You would go,
okay,
well is that evidence of racism?
That's why they're being prosecuted,
or is it evidence that they're
committing far more crimes?
Is it a combination of both?
Is it a lack of social awareness that
has allowed these inner cities to get
completely out of hand and these
impoverished neighborhoods the.
Yeah,
I think that,
but all the fury is just going to be
that.
He was like,
you know,
some black bitch basically,
just to just be so dismissive.
This no one's carrying about the
statistics he's throwing out.
They're only focusing,
but my point is you can get those facts
out.
If it had been a bunch of Irish people
and he was like,
you know,
this,
this mic ginger fuck just punched me,
punched me in the face because he's
white.
He could do it,
but he could do it.
But then his tweets would resonate more.
It wouldn't make any kind of news,
but at least it would resonate more if
he had some kind of facts and figures to
support,
you know,
whatever the violence problem.
I find it interesting though that after
all this recent shit about him being
racist,
that he doesn't just kinda back off and
just for like a year talk about cupcakes
or something.
He's actually pushing it almost to the
point of like,
like
you're like is really proven
my speech and,
and,
and everything like that.
He's almost to make a point about,
you know,
what,
what do you,
what are the examples you're talking
about?
Well,
like,
you know,
after all this thing of him being racist
on twitter.
Then he started going off on Ferguson
Ferguson stuff and then.
Well,
what did you see when you talk about
things like that,
like do you know specifically what he
said about Ferguson?
I know I can pull it up at that memory.
What we know is about what Joe Derosa
talked about the other day,
but he didn't cite any specifics either.
So I don't know what Anthony said about
Ferguson.
If I knew that I can comment on it
specifically.
Well,
I mean,
I mean I follow them on twitter and he.
He's still doing silly things that you
think about Ferguson.
Yeah.
You gotta keep blowing stuff up to go
that deep into that point.
What I'm saying is you can go on his
twitter and see what I'm saying,
but what I'm talking about,
he doesn't back off.
Well,
he doesn't have.
He doesn't.
He doesn't back off for a reason.
It seems like.
I think most people,
if you got that much,
like you lost your job,
you got in trouble on twitter about a
certain subject.
Then I'm like alright,
I'm not going to talk about Pi for
awhile.
Definitely
because he.
Because he immediately show,
yeah,
he immediately made like a chunk of
money,
you know,
it's like a netflix subscription type
thing.
So he immediately made like a gang of
money off that I assume so.
I don't know.
I don't know how well he's doing,
but I hope he does.
Well.
I thought that it'd be probably smarter
if he did it through subscription that
way more or through,
um,
through advertisers because advertisers,
that way,
you know,
it's going to get a large number of
people that are gonna listen to it
because if it's free,
you know,
like,
but he's Kinda like hamstringing himself
by making a subscription service.
But I think it's tough to make it costs
money.
Like you're definitely cutting people
out of it,
but I think there'll be an initial
thing,
but you have to like get people to catch
latch on board.
It's really hard to get people to pay
for Shit on the Internet in this day and
age.
Howard Stern Howard stern gives you
like,
you know,
I mean you basically are paying for
serious for like that or,
and a.
and you can't argue that like starring
channel that gives you tons of energy
for what you're paying.
Like he gives you a lot of different
stuff.
It's like him all day and other shows
and there's old content and just like
fun productions and stuff.
But that's not online.
That's on serious.
It's like if you subscribed to series,
is that what you're saying?
You can get that online took.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but I'm saying but I told her for making
people pay for something.
But he had but he did 20 some years of
giving it for free.
So now you can get or you.
We're talking about two different
things.
We're talking about satellite radio or
we're talking about Internet
subscription.
Does he have an internet subscription?
Was same thing.
I mean it is like you could watch it
online sterns thing.
Well Sorta,
but it's satellite radio.
You're working for a company.
I mean it's not like what Anthony's
doing.
Anthony's doing completely independent
Internet subscription thing.
I was confused,
but now Howard went from being for free
to ask for basically it costs money to
listen to them if you want to.
I'm saying,
oop,
going from like,
you know,
he didn't live as a free and then years
of,
you know,
he wasn't a specific charge for Sirius
xm even though he was like,
yeah,
he wasn't.
But now he's asking for a netflix amount
of money for one show.
That's what I'm saying.
There's no variety.
There's no like,
uh,
he's not really giving you anything
besides.
Well,
that's very true to our show.
It's very different because first of
all serious is in so many cars.
When you buy it,
you buy it,
you get a 90 day subscription and it
plays and you get to listen to stern.
You get addicted to it and listen to all
the different music channels to get
addicted to it.
But you're paying for satellite radio.
You're not paying for a specific show on
the Internet.
That is a complete total difference in
what you're getting.
Like the get something on the Internet
is what I'm saying.
It's very difficult to pay for.
Get people to pay for something that's
on the Internet.
It's not difficult to get people to
subscribe to satellite radio,
especially the satellite radios in their
car.
Bazillions of people like Netflix and
that's all Internet based.
Yeah.
Netflix gives you thousands of options.
That's the point I'm making.
I think it's hard to be able to pay for
like one,
two hour show a day,
four days a week,
flicks his movies and television shows
me.
If you're paying for Netflix,
you're paying for something that you can
watch on television.
I mean it gives you a good watch,
anthony show on TV,
but that's not how most people are
probably watching it.
I bet the majority of the people that
listened to a show or getting it,
they're getting it on like as a,
as an audio thing that they listened to
on the subway or something or in the
car.
That's what most people do with these
things.
It's just it's hard to get people to pay
for Shit online.
You know what I mean?
People are trying to do it.
Like drive plus is a drive is a youtube
channel that I really love.
It's a.
it's all about very sports cars and the
inner workings of them and they do all
these really cool in depth pieces.
They just changed their format and then
it became drive plus and they made
people subscribed to it and the video
they did it to.
The first one was one that I was a part
of.
This shark works company that makes
these cars and the comments were just
filled with pissed off people.
He was so fucking mad.
I mean they were so mad that all of a
sudden they were going to be forced to
have to pay.
I forget what the amount of month is.
I don't think it was a lot like five
bucks or something.
I don't remember though.
And people,
the entire comments for the video was
all about people being angry that they
had to pay for it.
The to Hulu thing was with their or fall
off or whatever.
When they went from,
hey,
have it all for free to like now we
charge you.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I bet they lost a lot of people.
I mean that's just what happens.
People don't want to pay for shit,
but Netflix is so good.
There's so much stuff and they have
their own independent programming like
that house of cards show or they're
doing a Chelsea handler's going to do a
show on it,
like they're.
They're actually becoming like a
network,
so if you pay x amount a month for it,
the amount of content that they have
access to is fucking incredible.
I like that plan to or they just
released the season as a whole right
away.
That really does make for like,
well there's also some weird shit that
goes on with them with like cable
Internet providers and did different
internet providers.
Like now they're going to have to pay
more because they use up more like they
have to cut deals.
Otherwise they throttled back netflix
users.
There's a lot of like weird shady shit
when it comes to like bandwidth and how
much bandwidth is worth and how much
bandwidth gets soaked up by different
applications.
Which shitty Ben Affleck,
Justin timberlake movie
or you're going to make about that guys
fighting for bandwidth.
The behind the scenes war
with wars.
Yeah.
It's tricky,
man,
if you're trying to sell shit online,
unless you're a Netflix,
like if hbo became an online thing only
even with all their awesome shows that
they have there will be tough.
Although that said the hipsters have
dominated that world and a lot of them
don't do cable at all and just get like
a subscription to hbo go and Showtime
Dot Com and all that stuff and they
watch all their shit like that.
Well there's a lot of people that do it
through itunes.
Yeah,
you do like apple,
you know,
you'd get an apple tv thing and you kind
of get a switch and all those things.
It's probably cost you somewhere like 50
bucks a month and you could be pretty
much have access to everything like the
next day.
Pretty close.
I mean there's a lot of shit you get.
I mean I use a itunes for a.
I use the apple TV to watch that show,
the strain and I tried to watch it on
regular TV.
Oh my God.
The fucking commercials make you
hemorrhage.
You can't leave.
How often the fucking commercials come
on.
It's like a couple minutes in Bam as
another commercial and then a couple
minutes after that,
Bam,
there's another commercial like,
oh my God,
like they just assault you with
commercials.
I keep cable direct TV for a few.
One of the football package is huge,
but two,
there's also something that makes me
feel like an adult having,
having,
having a cable.
Do you know what I mean?
Like you're supposed to have cable.
I don't know why,
but it really does.
It mean just like a.
either I stopped now but for a long
time.
Well,
beyond needing one.
I always had a house phone,
like a land logs.
I was like,
you're supposed to have a landline just
in case,
but it's just gone off the cell phone
now
after a while.
Well it's also like you don't ever want
to have something that you can't just
turn off.
Yeah.
The beautiful thing about cell phones
just shut that bitch off and nobody can
put.
Yeah.
But um,
yeah,
like those,
a lot of people do that Netflix thing
now where they don't have cable.
I just have netflix and use the computer
for shit.
And then hook up one of those.
I do it right now.
I just went and it's great because you
could just target what you want instead
of listening to background noise.
Pretty much.
Yeah.
That's probably smart.
Keep you from watching as much stuff
too.
Not just flipping through the channels
and then you want,
you know,
sometimes there's a search process to
like,
what do I want to see here?
And you'd go on and sometimes I'll take
a half an hour just looking for a good
movie to watch.
It's just wasted half hour here.
But like having cable,
like I'll never seek out the movie
breaking ever again.
But I'll watch the last 45 minutes of it
three times a week if it plumps on.
Yeah.
If I'm flipping through the channels and
roadhouse comes on,
it's like 2:00
and you're not going to stop.
I'm going to wash that shit.
It's like a gift of the universe.
If you're like alone in a hotel room,
flipping through the channels and
Roadhouse,
you're on the road,
he'll start laughing.
You gotta watch it.
You owe it to the Jeff Healey band to
deal with.
I want you to be nice until it's time to
not be nice.
How I know that is.
I will tell you,
my mom used to come home from work in
the middle of the night and feed my
little brother.
We didn't
have cable and we had a VCR and we had
roadhouse and she'd watch roadhouse
every night.
My mother knows every road roadhouse.
That's ridiculous.
Yeah,
it was a vhs.
Whoa.
You have vhs.
Oh my God.
I had that and hard to kill on the same
tape and we watched it constantly.
You know what's amazing?
If you could go back in time to when
those,
uh,
video stores were out,
like a local video store is like every
community.
How to like a local video store,
like a mom and pop video.
Sure.
And then the blockbuster came in and
fucking,
oh my God,
blockbusters.
Gonna shut down all these mom and pop
video stores.
And a lot of ways they did.
Except blockbuster didn't have porn.
That's what kept them alive.
So if you wanted to get the porn,
you'd have to go to the mom and pop
video stores came back to that day when
those things were all like everywhere
and you said within a couple of decades
these won't even exist anymore to go.
You're gone.
You're going to get everything out of
the air.
People will be like,
what?
Yeah,
he just going to press a button on a
machine and you're going to get it out
of the air specifically for porn.
What you had to go through to like our
franchise in Philly,
we had a place called west coast video
and you had it all and there's red
boxes.
Everything was going to have red box.
There was no,
like the covers were up on the wall.
You got a red box.
And the beauty of that was I would try
to just like find like my mom and step
pop would rent porno movies when I was
younger I guess for them,
for themselves.
And I would they leave in the VCR.
We only had one VCR,
so they,
I guess they'd watch it when I stayed at
my grandma's and I'd come,
I'd see the title of it and I will
always find titles that weren't very
porn sounding and then I would go stay
at my grandma's the next night and I
would tell her like,
hey,
if I reserve movies,
go pick them up and I would reserve.
That's it.
My little grand mom,
go pick up porn movies for me.
It's God.
She'd be wanting to make popcorn and
we'll watch it together.
I'm like,
Oh,
I'm going to probably watch it later.
Did she ever call you on it now?
But one time I never returned one and
they ended up calling and uh,
to keep it,
I just tried to keep.
It was a terrible.
It wasn't even a point.
It was when I rented,
it was like a,
like a skit,
a maxi type thing.
I had a friend that if the videos were
really good,
he would not bring them back because he
was like,
I'll take the penalty.
I need to keep this one borns.
Oh,
I had a guy take me a court for that,
for not returning and then eventually,
like the only reason I got the hook
eventually is it was a mom and pop place
that went on there.
It's called wow video.
There was a mom and pop place when I
used to hang out this pool hall in White
Plains,
New York,
and there was a mom and pop place across
the street that they found out had tracy
lord videos that were illegal.
Wow.
And the guys at the pool hall found out
about it and so they took them all and
they,
uh,
they pay the penalty on all of them.
They just like,
they're like,
these are valuable because she's under
age and I'm like,
Bro,
that shit,
what the fuck you doing?
She means she looked like she was of
age.
She had large breast diseases and she
was,
she looked like she was enjoying it
sexually.
This big banana tits.
Yeah.
They were weird sets,
but I'm beautiful girl.
But anyway,
she was fucking like 17 years old or 16
years old at the time when they were.
When she was making these big soft.
These guys found out about it.
Yeah.
Well the whole deal.
She was a woman.
I mean she looked like a woman.
She's obviously a little girl,
but if you looked at her like,
what is that?
You'd say,
well that's a naked woman.
No,
no,
no.
She's 16.
You piece of shit.
What the fuck?
How would I know you showed me or naked.
I watch a documentary is like,
her boyfriends were like in their mid
twenties,
early thirties and shit with none of
them have any idea.
You mean the guys on the show?
Our actual boyfriends.
She had her boyfriend show orange.
I'm calling the porn video.
This show,
the guy that she dated the porn stars
for Awhile.
Oh,
she dated this guy,
Tom Byron.
Remember when there's only like four
dudes porn stars like Peter North.
Tom Is always the first one because he
shut the biggest load.
Isn't it?
Weirdly gay?
That's the reason it's gay or that he
did gay porn did before that.
Yeah,
he did gay porn,
uh,
wasting those big loads on dude buts I
don't know about wasting.
I'm enjoying it and this is pre Viagara,
so he was really getting hard for gay
guys.
He stayed in there like he stayed in the
game a really long time simply because
of those loads.
There were ridiculous.
The fact that I know what you're talking
about,
like if you brought it up about any
other performer,
you'd be like,
I'm calling them performer.
What do you call them?
What do you call a guy?
This artist's chicks,
adult artists.
Peter North powerhouse,
sort of everybody knew those were the
things you knew Ron.
Jeremy can count down from 10 and income
and Peter North shoots,
but I didn't know that.
Everybody knows that.
I didn't fucking know that you guys had
jeremy know that all was porn is what he
would do.
He's counting down from 10 or it has the
girl countdown and then when she says
when he pulls out and blows a load,
no kidding.
Really.
I had no idea.
No idea about that either.
Yeah,
that's a weird thing to know.
You guys take a little time into another
hedgehog.
Watch it.
How many points have you watched?
Oh,
tons.
I stack collection action.
Yeah.
And all the tapes were the tapes were
red rose,
like shitty colors to read.
Videotapes.
Yeah,
right.
The cheapest fucking stuff that I had a
friend side.
I had a friend who had two vcrs,
black dude named frank.
He would just make compilation of like
his favorite come a great.
They were great to borrow.
No because whatever it was,
it was like fat ass white bitches and
then just be like all.
So he was like the first compilation
guys because they have compilations now
the way before the Internet.
But I think if I was a,
I'd have a severe problem if I grew up
with like the Internet.
It was good that I was here that I had
to like really work to get my porn use
severe problem if you had instant
access.
Absolutely.
And I feel so young.
I think a lot of people do have a
problem and I think it's as someone who
has a daughter,
I fucking hate that.
You know,
facial cumshots as part of the common
day,
you know what I mean?
Like that's what you do right out of the
gates center sex to right as the gates
sexually know.
One girl,
like I said,
I'm not going back to that.
I'm 36 years old,
but I do remember in school like the
girls who fucked it was kind of quiet
and the ones who everybody knew fucked
were kind.
They were kind of Shitty to them.
They kind of got like,
you know,
like oh she's a slut.
Which was just all the guys wishing they
were fucking,
you know,
wishing they were fucking her but still
like vilify,
you know,
I think,
I think the Internet is just like made
that completely like 16 year old girls
talking about who sucks Dick Better.
That's crazy.
Is that really what's going on?
Are you there when this is happening?
Are you hearing rumors now?
It's happening.
No,
no,
sure.
I have siblings who were very younger
than me because I was step father.
So I have a sister who still in high
school.
Oh.
So I mean like she's,
you know,
hopefully the best of my knowledge not
doing this stuff,
but they were doing a thing a few years
ago where the,
uh,
the kids would wear the colors,
you snap off the color,
that means like,
you know,
finger your asshole in the locker room
and then you go do it.
And the girls would always be like,
ugh,
so unfair like walk and they would just
go do it because he goes,
oh yeah,
that was the rule of bracelet rule.
If you imagine if that was going on when
I was young,
I don't know,
I would never be a comic,
that's for sure.
I would have got nothing done.
Do you really believe that though?
Yeah.
You would eventually become a comic.
You would just get bored of it.
Maybe.
But I mean I,
even now I had one point,
I lived with a guy who worked for the
cable company,
so we got unblocked.
Just a shitty playboy channel.
Like how benign the playboy channel is.
And if I was playing madden on the
loading screens on playstation two,
I would constantly flip back,
like back and forth to the playbook to
see whatever it was [inaudible] there'll
be a girl with her pussy out and that
would just for some reason I like,
I'm going to watch that for a minute and
then come back to the loading screen
date.
Remember when they had fake porn that
like Emmanuelle series on showtime.
You'd watch these weird movies.
It was like kind of,
it wasn't,
it was romance that wasn't designed for
women.
It was like romance that was designed
for couples or men to watch.
So it eventually got two people having
sex.
But all you really saw was like you saw
breasts and he saw the man,
like fake humping the girl.
But he knows he saw no penetration.
But you could tell like their organs
were ms.like
their sexual organs were not lined up
correctly.
Was blowing them.
But she's like head butting him in the
chest.
Yeah.
And if he was banging her like where's
her pussy sitting there and belly
buttons.
Weird.
Some strange place.
None of it made any sense,
you know,
and,
but they were fake Moan,
uh,
and they were always on late at night.
That crap,
man,
do they.
I couldn't jerk off that.
Now if I tried for a long,
there's no way I'm too far gone.
Yeah,
you can't go back.
But you could if you were like trapped
though,
like if you were like in the Amazon
jungle for like six months and then all
of a sudden you got to a hotel room
like,
oh my God,
tv and you flip through the channels and
carry on.
Emmanuelle was on and it was like little
shitty filter because there are those
cameras they used back then were dog
shit.
So it was like there was no adhd really
low and kind of Fuzzy and Oh,
I used to be able to jerk off to like
the girls gone wild like promo video on
like each channel night.
But I mean it's just like,
that's just such a thing of the past.
I couldn't even.
Everyone was like,
how could you,
why you couldn't get so excited to the,
uh,
the fattening thing.
All the celebrity nudes that came out
because still images.
I can't check off the still images
anymore.
Yeah,
and the only thing that's hard about it.
Well they're hot,
but it's just that they're famous and
you know them from something else.
That's always a big thing about porn
stars.
It's like people used to have this idea,
at least that the really beautiful women
were important stars to really beautiful
women were like Cindy Crawford or you
know,
whoever fill in the blank.
Farrah Fawcett,
those are the really beautiful ones.
And the porn stars zero.
A couple of notches behind.
But there's porn stars today that are
fucking tens.
Yeah.
Unbelievably beautiful.
If you look at and be like,
that girl could be Lindsay Lohan.
She could be a supermodel.
She could be anything.
And she's just getting old.
Yeah.
Good Dick,
you know,
talk about.
But they've also like removed like the
excitement of exits.
So out there like there's still
something more exciting if you saw a
girl that was hot at the gas station and
somehow you were able to see her 10
minutes later,
like do something where you opened the
door by accident.
She was naked.
That's way more exciting.
Do you know what I mean?
I guess because you're seeing them.
It's from a different context.
Like a porn star,
you know you're going to see if that
same pornstar happened to be the star of
a Sitcom and you saw her naked.
That would make that so much more
exciting.
But the fact that she's,
you know her from sucking Dick,
like seeing her pussy.
Isn't that exciting?
I guess I see what you're saying.
Yeah.
Unless you weren't being inundated with
porn.
See if you.
If you're being inundated with porn,
I think that's the real issue is you get
numb to the porn and then with the real
excitement is like,
oh,
I'm not supposed to be seeing this porn.
So it makes it exciting.
My favorite comment,
if you weren't going video shit,
if you weren't getting inundated with
porn and then you saw some porn,
some naked sex,
you'd be like,
well this is great.
You get excited.
Oh yeah.
Numbness.
That's what it is.
Yeah.
Well you're also get like A.
I think I also used to be able to jerk
off and fucking three minutes.
Now it's like a.
it's a whole process because you're
like,
I could find a better video.
It's like a challenge to yourself and
then the head shake.
You make it yourself when you're just
jerking off to that third one you found
like 40 minutes later you're like,
come on man,
I could have made phone calls.
I got emails to send out a lot of shit
done.
Yeah,
and here I am right back at the same
stupid bachelor party gang.
Bang.
Well it's like those a monkey tests they
do with cocaine and heroin and give the
monkey heroin.
They take the heroin once a day and
they're straight.
They give them monkeys coke and they
just keep hitting that coke button until
they're fucking hearts explode.
You know?
There's something about giving guys
access to constant 24 hour porn.
I mean that's where all that gagging
shit and gaping and fucking all the
abuse porins got to become violent.
Well,
it comes out like,
what's next?
We've done all this.
What's next?
We're going to fucking pee and girls'
butts.
Okay,
okay.
How about we p and girls' butts and we
attached a Straw that pee pee and we
make them drink it out of their own.
But that guy's in jail.
I said,
yeah,
he hasn't yelled is out now as you ever
see that documentary and Max Heart Max
hardcore.
Did you ever see that documentary
called hardcore where the girl comes
over from England?
It's a.
it'll make you like furious at that guy.
You ever seen it before?
I think I saw clips of it on effect.
It's a,
it's a girl who comes from England,
you know,
porn producers like your beautiful baby
you're going to do basically starts off.
We're just gonna do like pictures and
lesbian porn.
And then before you know it,
like they get to sets and it's like,
well I thought you said we're just going
to watch today.
It's like,
no baby.
Come on.
Like I told him,
you're doing this anal porn today.
She's like,
well,
I said no anal.
And he's like,
wow,
come.
It's more money if you do it.
And it's really watching them break a
girl down to a one point,
a Max hardcore,
I believe it is getting ready to do
something terrible to her.
And she finally,
after crying he,
she said she didn't want to do it.
The first thing he does is he walks into
a room when she's going to meet Max
Hardcore for the first time,
a bunch of people in this room and the
documentary crew,
he walks in,
he shakes everyone's hand and goes over
to her,
seems very real.
Pulls her panties down and stuffs as
Dick in her asshole.
And she makes a face like it's pretty
real.
And she gets weeded out.
And then he goes,
let's go upstairs.
He starts talking into a scene.
She says she doesn't want to do it.
He gets really,
first thing he tries to do is hit her
with the baby.
You're beautiful,
you're going gonna.
Make a lot of money.
This is a great thing.
People want to see your beautiful body.
He does that for about five minutes and
then he kicks right into you.
Stupid Bitch,
check or whatever.
Go back to England and tell your kid you
can't take care of her and just fucking
okay,
good.
Can waste my fucking time.
And then she agreed to do it and the
documentary guy step in and they turn
the camera off and just says like,
at this point we thought she wasn't
responsible for self anymore.
They pulled her out of it.
Okay.
Is this a hundred percent confirmed?
Did you sure that this wasn't in any way
set up?
That's why you know,
like there's a lot of these porn
scenarios where they do a casting
couches.
No,
no,
but there's a documentary couches.
No,
I know that there's other ones that they
do where it's totally rigged.
Yeah.
I think most of them always rig,
this is not a thing.
This is a full length,
like two hour documentary.
It's about this girl that was just one
scene,
but they showed him fucking her in the
ass.
She doesn't.
She's not opposed.
Okay.
But she goes,
yes,
yes.
They say,
well they don't show it as dick going in
because it's just not the way.
It's a documentary guy.
So it's like if it happened in the
corner over there.
So they're not showing the actual sex.
Yes,
they show it.
They just don't show the penetration.
But you see him put his dinner and she
and her makeup face and get weird.
I don't know if that's.
I don't know if that's a setup.
You know what I'm saying?
Like do you know that that's not a set
up.
Obviously I can't confirm it to 107.
Do a weird thing in this documentary.
Sounds like a real documentary.
I mean if it wasn't a porn documentary,
they would show like real porn.
Yeah.
No,
they don't show.
There's no penetration.
Doesn't necessarily mean it's true that
that's not necessarily true.
I mean,
I don't know.
I see what you're saying.
Like it sounds like it could be real,
but it also could be something that they
set.
I don't
know anything good,
but you know what I mean?
It's the same.
That same world.
You know what I'm saying?
That world of the fake auditions that
turn,
but this isn't.
This isn't a,
this isn't a jerk off bubble thing in
any way.
This whole thing is terribly like,
what the fuck is this guy doing?
This girl was like,
is he really doing that?
It's not a.
Oh,
okay.
It's not,
it's not.
There's no fancy.
You sit around and you see the
documentary guys like,
like even like the,
you know,
the guys talking to each other like
this,
like should we do something?
So He's just an evil guy that's out of
control.
Abusing the shit out of chicks and
putting it on video.
I've heard them on Howard Stern.
Right?
It seems like a pretty horrible dude,
but I'm having a little bit,
but it seemed like a horrible dude.
This is a road Dr.
hold on a second.
What'd you hear?
That he seemed like he was a horrible on
Howard stern is the way he talked.
The girls come in,
they want to be porn stars and he just
like,
he doesn't mean.
It's like,
well you're a little fat,
but you know,
I can work with that,
you know,
right.
Pig on your face.
And he just kinda like,
it's like a gruff,
like shitty guys.
Maybe it's a character for all I know,
but I heard,
but why be the villain?
I mean the guy did go to jail.
I don't know.
You know what that was for?
So I'll show you exactly what it was
before he went to jail for.
No,
really?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Obscenity laws.
It's a very scary thing.
Look,
I don't think that would he see.
It's a tricky situation because I think
anybody with any ethics or morals that
looks at that guy and what the kind of
videos he did,
you don't want to be attached to that.
It's disgusting.
I mean if even if it is fake,
it's still like,
man,
what?
Why does this get you off?
Like you're just,
you're being fucking horrible to these
people if that's really what gets you
off.
Like what kind of a human being run,
what kind of uh,
what kind of a product are you selling.
But the way they got them is there are
certain places that have like really
strict obscenity laws and so they
prosecuted him in Florida and it's one
area that had these really brutally
strict obscenity laws.
So they went after this guy,
they targeted him,
I think they saw the videos and he
decided this is a piece of shit and we
need to put this guy in jail.
And they in their eyes,
the prosecutors eyes.
I think if I had a guess that they found
a guy who had made this sort of a evil
business off of a loophole and that
loophole was the,
the freedom of expression that he's
allowed to have his own artistic
interpretation of what's porn and what's
not porn.
But anybody like you,
that's a normal guy who wants to,
you like,
this guy's a piece of shit.
Like he's making movies for fucking evil
people.
Yeah.
To to want to get off to that as a very
bizarre thing to me it is.
It's definitely very bizarre,
but it's also like at what point in time
is it censorship at one point in time is
like,
who's to say that you can't.
I mean if you made a movie,
okay,
this is a totally unrelated thing,
but if you made a movie about a guy who
was a horrible serial killer,
right?
And he's very statistic and it's part of
the entertainment is this guy's very
sadistic and then as long as someone
catches that guy and kills him,
most of us are like,
wow,
that was a fucked up movie,
but they got them in the end.
The problem with this is nobody gets it
in the end except the girl girl gets it
in the end.
You know what I mean?
Like the girl gets abused and it's about
abuse and that's it.
There's no narrative.
There's no like story arch arch where
someone comes along and they fucking
find this guy and they lock them up in
jail at the end and then everybody feels
safe.
Now.
It's just awful from the beginning to
the end.
It's awful.
And then it ends.
There's no plot.
It's just him violating somebody and
this and this.
But it rolls on without him though.
I mean there's like a thousand Max
hardcore,
I'm sure.
Right.
Those guys,
they'll put on a on effect.
I've seen them do those,
uh,
the compilations of like,
just not even the sex part,
just the guy's being mean to the chair.
It's like they,
they bring in like awful,
like unattractive women and they shit on
them and then fuck them.
It's very weird.
Yeah.
And they smack 'em they sign up for the
news is like physical abuse.
That would be illegal and you would
actually go to jail for like,
you can't smack a chicken the face,
but you can't,
you can't really set a waiver to say
that's okay.
I,
you sorta can.
I mean like wrestling,
right?
Ah,
but it's different if it's a guy
smacking a woman.
I mean,
let's be honest,
isn't it?
I'm morally,
if a guy saw them,
if they're doing a wrestling match and a
guy smacks the guy,
these guys are,
they're agreeing to this.
They're both guys.
If two girls are doing it,
they're both girls.
But if a guy does it do a girl.
But I mean there's been,
there has to have been pro wrestling
storylines where the guy accidentally
swings and smacks the girl.
Like that's part of the story lines.
Uh,
I mean,
I just watched the other day a triple h
put Stephanie Mcmahon and the pedigree.
Well in movies for sure there's been
domestic violence in movies without a
doubt.
But they're not really.
No,
no,
no.
But they're not really hitting.
That's the actual contact.
Nowhere in pro wrestling there is
conscious that's the difference.
And progressing,
they're actually hitting.
So if you've,
there's absolutely TV shows and movies
that they hit each other.
No.
You see a woman hit a man.
You never see a man actually hit a woman
in a movie that,
a recent movie.
Well,
I bet you there is in the last year some
show that you have a,
a man hit a woman and it's a real hit.
No,
they can make no jersey shore though.
but that wasn't set up.
You can make it look like it's a real
fear.
You could make it look like it,
but I've never seen.
I've never seen a woman cough,
a man or a man cuff,
a woman in the face where I thought it
was real.
That Jersey shore,
a Snooki got punched in the face by
dude.
Yeah.
That was real hundred percent versus 100
or she got blasted and that's the type
of thing you can't fake.
I mean she just got popped.
That guy was a fucking savage.
That guy was a schoolteacher.
I know an MMA fighter.
Was He really?
Yeah.
I mean he just uncorked on her face.
I guess MMA has been around long enough
now.
There's just finally there's some guys
coming out and disgracing the sport a
little bit.
There's always going to be crazy people
and everything.
Sports players,
fucking whatever competition.
Aggressive Holo athletes or people that
are nuts.
You're going to run into people,
I mean in the most unlikely scenario,
if it's a competition,
you know you're going to run into not
even if it's a competition,
there's
probably asshole dentists that'll punch
in the face of they're doing shots and
then sometimes it works out as mma.
Guys,
it works out great.
What?
Remember that was at a world star hip
hop video with the.
Was it down in DC?
Kind of unassuming white dude.
Oh,
Ryan Hall dropped a big black guy.
Right.
And the guy who gave up eventually.
Yeah.
And then it shows white party,
the black dudes later and mounted them.
Do you need me to kick his ass?
Just held him down and just our grappled
and let them know.
Yeah.
Let them know that it's going to get
worse.
That's so awesome.
Yeah.
Well especially if you haven't grappled
before,
you get tired so quick like,
okay,
get off me.
Like you don't have enough energy left
to attack them.
Like there's nothing left.
I love.
I love bullies getting knocked out
video.
I do love those.
Those make me happy.
It's nice when you see that as comics.
I think what you said about the thing
about punching up earlier,
it really is like we do seek justice to
some degree.
For sure.
The,
I just have a problem with the statement
that all good comedy is punching up.
That's just not true.
It's a lot of good comedy that's
punching sideways in a lot of good
comedy that's punching down,
but there's no but,
but Louis Ck shitting on his daughter.
There's no,
like a lack of justice there.
Do you know what I mean in that regard?
Because you said you kind of know it's
not only as an implied,
it's very obvious.
He's kidding.
He loves his kid.
Nobody makes an outward.
Uh,
and it's funny.
No one does make it our thing with the,
the fights people choose to pick.
When I did,
uh,
interestingly enough with the daughter
thing,
right?
I did fallon a,
I talk shit about my daughter for the
first two minutes of it.
And then I did Michael Vick jokes and
thousands of hate mails the next day
poured in over these Michael Vick jokes
over imaginary dot.
I say that,
uh,
he was on my team,
so I have to love him because he's on my
team at the time.
He's on the Eagle still and I say,
uh,
I go,
you know,
I know he's a terrible dude and did some
terrible things,
but while he's on my team,
just when like I'll throw him a dog,
let them tear it apart,
like a wearable for the end zone if he
scores.
And I said I'd mail them a box of
puppies with a photograph of me shushing
if he wins the super bowl and it killed
in the room at the end.
But then all the hate mail came in for
that.
And it was such a weird thing.
It's like not one person was like,
how do you shit talk your daughter like
that,
you know,
you're telling a joke about shitting on
her father's day present or something
she got for you.
It's like no one cares,
but then there.
But there was petitions online for a
public apology from me for imaginary
dogs.
Dogs that don't exist.
Well,
once
things happened,
people get excited and they want action.
They want,
they want you to apologize and if they
can force you into action that they've
won some sort of an online contest,
you know,
they've decided.
They've written a blog about it.
They started the Hashtag make Jay
Oakerson Hashtag make jay apologize
specifically.
It's so bizarre to get that wound up
about comedy ever.
I don't get about everything man.
I mean every fucking youtube video that
comes out as a thousand comments.
People at Duke it out in the comment
section and people get fired up about
almost everything and anything and if
they have the license to be offended if
people have the license to be offended,
like they could think that what you said
is not funny.
You know,
they can think that what said is cruel,
but this licensed to be offended.
You have her on my show.
Again,
this is my show.
I like to show
actually blown away though,
like offended people get us,
but I feel like comedy should be void of
that.
Of course.
Yeah.
But sometimes I feel like we're treated
like we're speaking to fucking congress,
given affidavits in court.
There's a laughing microphone behind me
on a sign,
you know,
like what do you,
will you see what's going on?
People are just getting attention.
You talk about it and you engage them
and they get to be upset about you and
find other folks that are upset about it
as well.
Everybody gets to be good to have a
little attention to.
That's why,
you know,
it's obviously one of the most famous
moments on the show,
but that's why I was always.
I was,
I was very,
uh,
tight with Kilstein Jamie Kilstein and
one point I'm like,
as a comic coming out against comedy
that,
that blew my mind so much when that
happened.
Yeah.
The thing about still once in a while,
yeah,
I was still once in a while,
go back and watch that whole thing
because I'm trying to get where he was
coming from with that.
Where he's coming from.
It
is a very rigid ideology.
There's a very rigid ideology of,
you know,
what,
what the,
the down the people that are talking
down on it,
we call it the social justice warriors.
They talk about it in a mocking sense,
social justice warriors,
but social justice warriors like the
idea behind like this super male
feminists,
very liberal,
very,
you know,
a lot of them Vegan like this,
this whole idea of do the least amount
of harm possible.
They have a very rigid ideology when it
comes to certain things.
They don't leave any room for certain
things to be discussed in a mocking
manner,
you know,
and I think that you get stuck in that
world if you're in that world.
Like they have very rigid rules.
They don't think you should ever say a
joke about rape was really fucked up.
As Jamie had one about rape.
It was about men getting raped and that
was okay.
It's like you can't,
you can,
you just can't have any mocking jokes
about any woman getting raped.
Even if the Daniel tosh situation,
it was like such an obvious line that
she yells out during is if no one knows
the scenario.
Tosh was on stage and he was asking the
audience what they wanted to talk about
because like occasionally someone will
yell out a subject and it'd be pretty
funny,
you know,
and then you may be able to come up with
a bit from it.
Who knows?
He's just having a good time with the
crowd being loose adlibbing.
Some guy yells,
talk about rape,
and he goes and he starts listing off
all the thing that's not funny about
rape.
Like what are you talking about?
What is it?
The humiliation,
the physical violence like what part do
you think is funny?
And this woman like self righteously
yells out.
Actually there's nothing funny about
rape as if he didn't know that is.
If he wasn't saying that exact same
thing and he goes,
wouldn't be funny.
Five guys raped right now.
Like,
and then everybody starts howling
laughing.
Why?
Because it's a funny thing to say in
that moment.
Sure.
Into argue against that.
Saying like that promotes a culture that
accepts rape is completely ridiculous.
What it promotes is,
is rallying against people that are
stating the obvious there,
stating the obvious to take moral high
ground.
Actually,
there's nothing funny about rape.
Like he was saying that very thing with
humor that there is nothing funny about
rape.
When she chimed in,
it's a person that wanted attention.
That's the same person that wrote that
blog.
She wrote a blog about it.
That very person was like the nightmare
person to say that too because she went
and she wrote this blog and then he
wound up giving us like fake apology,
which is pretty hilarious
to show you.
Did you see,
uh,
what law and order Svu did with that
story?
They made that into.
They did.
Oh yeah.
You know,
they do the polls from the headlines.
So they had the guy,
first of all,
they refer to them as like the like
where you going,
like we're going up to the college
campus to watch that.
That new rape comic is intentional.
They call him a rape comment was
Jonathan Silverman plays him.
That's hilarious.
The new rape coming in town.
So he goes up there and his jokes are
all about,
you know,
like fucking chicks against her will to
some degree,
but everyone loves him.
He's,
he's getting huge applause and cheers.
Oh my God.
The SV into.
What's funny about that is at one scene
after they,
they suspect a,
he goes on trial because a girl almost
got raped after his show.
A girl was a fan of his and they tried
to make the argument that these guys
wouldn't have tried to rape her if they
weren't all goosed up from his comedy
show.
Well that was the actual argument and
what they ended up doing with the story
was first thing they do,
it made me laugh was the whole Svu team
goes and sits front row at his comedy
show is what they do first and they're
just sitting there staring and shaking
their heads and you almost want to go.
You guys are actually being a pretty
shitty audience.
Like at the end of the day,
it's like if you're going to sit there
and stare at least sit in the back.
Like that seems like kind of a weird.
Like you're making the show get weird
and rapey by staring,
staring at him,
but then when they do,
the big payoff is at the end of the
whole episode.
They make that.
He was also a rapist.
A.
I actually tweeted out,
I was like pretty fucking irresponsible.
Like that's a really irresponsible thing
that for the first show I got to do.
You would think that it,
by the way,
the kind of people that actually would
be rapists,
they would be talking about how rape is
awful because they would probably be
trying to throw people off the yes,
they wouldn't be like raping all the
time and then joking about rape and all
the time like that sounds like the exact
opposite of what you would do if you
were trying not to get busted being a
fucking rapist.
Crack jokes.
Are you trying to loosen people's
expectations?
Remember there was a comedian rapists
remember that?
Oh yeah.
That would backtrack of schools.
He would go to colleges and he would
rape girls at colleges and he would ask
them to pray for him.
Really?
Vince champ.
Yeah,
but they need to do a thing,
but then he'd do.
He would go like those block bookings,
like he would go to one school,
pick up the check,
go to the next goal and then double
back.
So that's how the.
I think he pulled it off for awhile.
I didn't know he had a strategy.
Did you have a strategy and what?
I understand I could be wrong with that
obviously,
but that's where I've.
I've heard that from several sources
that it was like a doubling back thing.
He won star search in 1992 and he's
serving a 55 to 70 year sentence for
committed at college campuses on a
standup circuit.
How many did they say?
How many rapes?
There's a bunch.
I don't know man.
The story I'm looking for has been
removed from the.
How many rapes were the while there was
somebody rapes
nineties.
Like I rates it was in the late
Yeah.
I don't know how many guys,
how many girls he raped,
but he would have asked them to pray for
them,
which is really fucked.
Rave.
The last thing a chick wants to hear
what you're raping them.
You feel bad about the rape.
I think rape,
rape,
there always has to be like,
it seems to me like there's gotta be a
shut up or I'll do this element to it
because I feel like you just couldn't.
It's like professional wrestling,
like how you couldn't suplex somebody
like a vertical suplex that doesn't want
to be suplex that you couldn't possibly
do it.
Someone I feel like,
how could you fuck someone who's really
snapping their legs shut and fighting.
That almost seems like it's an
impossible task.
Are you serious?
It's got physically for real.
Yeah.
I mean it's something that,
it happens all the time.
Obviously you can happen.
Nobody saying.
I think there's always an element.
I think eventually the girl kind of has
to do like some kind of like get this
fucking over.
If you fight physically fight the entire
time,
I think you almost couldn't pull it off.
Um,
I don't know,
man.
I think a guy could probably pull it
off.
I think they do.
I don't know even know what you're
saying.
Like guys,
definitely rape.
I know.
No girl,
no price.
Did it make it sound guy to say,
guys,
don't let guys girls fight them off.
Still rape him.
That shit happens all the time.
The land managers bigger,
you know,
big,
strong men and small women.
It's probably,
they hold you down.
The seems pretty obvious I think though
if needed.
Booze.
No,
I mean like if you like,
she's not going to be wet,
you know,
I'm not even talking about that.
I'm talking to someone like nonstop,
like physically flailing around,
like to completely subdue someone's for.
Have you ever just like playful?
He wrestled with the girl,
like with your girlfriend.
It was like,
uh Oh yeah,
my,
my chicken.
If I tried to hold her arms and a tickle
her and she's flailing like I don't
think I can control her feeling.
She's not a big girl at all.
I control my growers.
He can't move.
Brian Kicks Ass on police.
He's a fucking savage dude.
You could stop a rape.
Don't rape.
Don't forget all personal appearances.
Put that aside.
He's a savage.
Jesus Christ.
Control my girl.
Yeah,
you could look man.
If you know how to wrestle,
you could hold the chick down pretty God
damn easy.
It's not hard.
Could hold up dude down,
but you have to hold her down and
accomplish something that's sort of
intricate to some degree.
I don't know.
This is a weird thing to speculate.
Let's break it down.
How would you take it around the horn?
Classroom?
Judo,
throw the Jujitsu and I think that,
uh,
it probably be a Jew.
It's like especially there's a lot of
violence involved,
right?
Like hitting choking.
I don't think it would be hard.
I mean it would obviously it wouldn't be
as easy as like normal sex.
No,
that's almost making the point.
I'm saying by the time actually the sex
part happens.
I feel like there's just like give up to
some degree,
man.
Yeah.
I guess you can see me appearing at the
Tomahawk University started announcing
my college tour.
It's called the don't worry.
I don't believe I could possibly rape
you tour.
Hey,
everybody has their own confidence level
will put up.
They,
you pull off.
He can't pull off in this life if you
feel like you're limited in that regard.
I can never dunk a basketball and I
could never break.
I was in two things.
I physically can't pull off.
He's a fucked up thing,
man.
That that's like so common in the animal
community like violence and sex.
Like if you ever watched,
I was watching this documentary or is
listening to this podcast rather,
uh,
about Tasmanian devils and how vicious
Tasmanian devils are with each other and
that while they're having sex,
like they almost,
they always bite each other.
They're constantly biting each other and
they fuck each other's faces up like
when they have sex and they fuck each
other's faces up when they're fighting
over a meal.
They're constantly going at it.
But there was a disease that was
spreading amongst them.
It was actually a type of cancer and the
type of cancer was actually proving to
be,
um,
something that's contagious.
By some strange manner of evolution.
These cancerous cells would burst and
infect the cells around them.
And so they,
all these,
a Tasmanian Devil started dying off
because they started developing these
cancerous,
contagious tumors and they were
constantly biting each other in the face
so they would be biting into these
tumors and the tumors would like
literally make tumors on the other
animals.
Jesus.
Yeah.
But just constantly attacking fucking
mangling each other.
Like that's what they did.
They were just constantly like biting
when they fucked his back and they make
these crazy noises mad.
This guy who is a,
uh,
if you ever listen to radio lab,
you know,
what I'm talking about was amazing
podcast.
It's an amazing podcast.
And the podcast is all,
you know,
it's all like really interesting things
that are like one of them they had about
the problems with trying to communicate
with dolphins and just really
fascinating,
fascinating stuff.
One of them was on the apocalypse,
like how,
what the asteroid impact did and how
many animals were killed off and what
the original humans probably looked
like.
The thing that became a human that was
alive back then,
this fucking burrowing underground mammo
rodent type thing.
But um,
they were doing this,
this radio lab one on these Tasmanian
devils in this cancer that was
spreading.
It was fucking madness,
man.
Want to dig into stuff like that.
Too much of it gives me a genuine
anxiety,
especially apocalypse stuff.
Yeah.
But you know,
it's like,
oh,
it was always just a chance to meteor
size of Texas could destroy the earth,
which is weird that that became like a
thing with these animals that they would
bite and fuck while they're biting,
biting each other in the face.
And,
and that's not a discussion.
That's just nature.
What's the nature of it?
Yeah.
It's not like constantly do it.
Apparently they just bite.
They just always fighting over meat and
fucking biting each other in the face
and flux and kills like immediately.
So yeah,
same,
you know,
it's like sodas,
black widow,
right?
Yep.
That's real common insect community.
I on aunt wants this,
a weird fucking ant that takes,
they're almost all females and there's
occasionally males and when they find a
male,
they bite his legs off,
they bite his legs off and they bring
the males like slightly larger.
They bite his legs off and then they
carry them into the hive to breed and
then they wind up killing him.
They make him write a book.
They just need to cripple them.
He has like wings,
I think to get the story of misery.
You make them write a book of your
favorite character.
We have it.
So we are such pussies.
You know,
we,
we have a conversation about how
difficult it would be to rape somebody
and it's a dangerous subject to tread.
You look into the nature world.
It's like sex without rape.
They're like,
what are you talking about?
That doesn't even happen.
I wanted it.
I take it.
Yeah.
There's the,
that's how you make sure that are
fucking.
Well yeah.
And the,
the lion has to get through all the male
lions.
He has to prove his worth and then
eventually he's going to get pushed out
by some new young lions,
you know,
because he wants to keep like a few
checks around and some new young lines
again,
and then he's going to be out there on
his own.
They'd say that's like the biggest
problem in Africa.
Took a metaphor for snl for the new
line,
comes in,
the other one gets sent out to pasture,
so meadows ever watch that show,
but like with a African villages that
the real problem that they have is when
a lion gets cast out and the females
don't get the food anymore than the
lions have to go get their own food and
a lot of those old males,
they start to get crippled and slow and
the chip teeth off and shit.
Then they become super dangerous because
they can't get the normal game animals
they used to getting.
So then they start snatching people
just.
Oh yeah.
Just so I keep proving themselves.
Well,
there was a leopard writing.
There was a story about.
It was in the news yesterday about a
leopard in India that they'd taken us
responsible.
One individual leopard responsible for
15 deaths,
15 different people that had targets,
drunk people and that it waits.
Yeah.
Fucked.
Is that to grow?
Yes.
Spot.
Yeah.
Well people,
you know,
they go out and they start partying and
this leopard is apparently developed
this taste for drunk people.
Like he knows that when people come out
of these bars,
they're slow and they don't know what
the fuck's going on.
They're not on there,
they're not on the ball and they get
jacked.
It's almost weird to walk out of
anywhere in the world of a bar and
there's a leopard waiting for you.
Even in India.
India is scary with.
In fact,
in India I find it more weird.
There's a bar than a leopard waiting to
kill you.
I feel like the bombing.
There's bars and India.
Well,
you know,
it's interesting like India,
everybody always thinks of as being like
this place of peaceful meditation and
Yoga.
Right?
I mean that's.
A lot of people think of desert,
but you,
you hear about all these goddamn gang
rapes like India.
These stories of people getting like
gang raped on buses and women dying.
You don't.
You hear about those quite a bit like
that.
I wouldn't have normally associated that
with India.
You know,
we don't,
we don't think of that,
but it's like when you have a billion
people,
you get a lot of crazy shit going on.
You've got a billion people stuffed on
what continent he imagined.
Yes.
I mean the young people anywhere picking
up on that,
especially with Internet,
everything picking up on like the
culture of all that stuff.
So if you go to South Africa,
there street gangs,
you know and they think their bloods and
crips because that's what they see
really.
Sure.
Yeah.
I mean it's not,
I don't think there are directly
affiliated,
but there's like there's street gangs,
you know,
like that kind of thing in South Africa
with a weird place like that.
Do you remember
when there was an ice cube song about
moving the crips and the bloods to the
Midwest now was a song steady mom and I
think it was road trip.
It was,
yeah,
it was.
Who was something like that where these,
these gang bangers.
It got too hot and La.
So they set up gang affiliates in the
middle of the country.
Oh,
those are those like southern ones,
like those documentaries,
Hbo with the white boy gangs,
like just a bunch of dudes wearing like
bandannas over their face and caring.
Hey sickles.
More terrifying thing coming your way.
It's like the children of the corn with
Doo rags on.
What was that show?
It was like banging in this bank in
Little Rock and little rock.
That's.
Wow.
That's white trash guys.
Get him geary.
That scared a lot of people.
Oh yeah.
Banging in little rock type shit.
That scares a lot of people.
The idea that this gang violence that
you see in like Inglewood and Compton on
the television shows that that's somehow
under that Boyz in the hood.
Shit could somehow to make it.
Yeah.
And it's terrifying.
Split when you see in the south.
It's weird cause it looks.
It's already kind of a scary area of
like swampy overgrown hedges and stuff.
And then there's like there's like a
dude with an Uzi wearing a red flannel
and swampy Louisiana whether
and if you.
Yeah.
Fuck.
And if you're scared of it,
you're racist.
Just don't hit back.
You know,
I tell you what,
I've talked about some shit on this
podcast and gotten,
you know,
a lot of people's reactions about it.
But one of the biggest reactions I ever
got about anything I said was that I was
talking about John Jones and I said,
I wonder how much of like why is now
popular is racism.
I wonder if people are racist.
Even say you wonder that someone might
be racist.
Like if if someone's reaction to
something,
it's probably like flipping of me to say
like that's especially when you're not
considering it before you're saying it,
you're just discussing a subject because
you did.
It's interesting.
It's such a charged subject.
You've got to have a fully formed idea
before you say it.
But just the mere possibility that some
people can be racist was such a.
like people are so angry,
like not even saying you're racist.
Not saying the only way that you
couldn't.
Like the guy was because of racism.
I said,
I wonder how much of it is racism.
I wonder if it's a factor.
Because I always wonder about races.
I think he gives reasons beyond that,
but I think it's a fair question.
I mean he gives reasons to dislike him,
he see on race.
But
you know,
at the same time,
yes,
some people will just,
is it ridiculous?
The notion that people would just
blindly like thing just,
you know what I mean?
Like I don't know where we'll live in a
world of apologies,
don't apologize for asking.
Well,
it's,
it's just such a highly charged subject.
It's a fascinating thing that it's so
highly charged that you know,
even a mere suggestion and if people
thought in some way that I meant,
if you don't like them is because you
racist,
then that's my shitty job of
communicating an idea because that's
certainly was never what I was thinking.
But what I was thinking was,
I think I know for a fact when I was a
kid,
I used to root for white guys.
I just did like when George Gerry Cooney
fought Larry Holmes,
I remember very clearly being
embarrassed that I rooted for Gerry
Cooney because he was a white guy
because I remember Larry Holmes box the
shit out of him and he just picked them
apart.
And before that mean Gerry Cooney was a
really good fighter.
He was a,
he beat Ken Norton.
He knocked them out,
devastating knockout,
and it was like,
it was,
he was a good fighter,
but Larry Holmes was a master at the
time and it was just,
I should have been appreciating what
Larry Holmes was able to do to this guy
who'd been able to knock out some really
good fighters that Larry Holmes was just
using his skill and that it was.
But I had been rooting for Gerry Cooney,
so when he lost,
I was like,
Damn.
It was because it was,
it might've been because he was the
underdog too.
I was a kid.
I was dumb.
I know.
I was rooting for it because he was
white.
I know it was,
it was probably Blake.
I was a senior or a junior,
maybe a junior in high school.
So I guess I was 16 and uh,
yeah,
it was just dumb.
I mean,
it wasn't that I was racist because it's
been going well.
What we,
what you attach to the most,
like what you related to the most?
I could be that guy.
Yeah,
most certainly.
Most certainly.
Yeah.
But um,
I did it a little bit when I was 20,
not,
but not nearly as enthusiastic with
Tommy Morris screaming,
I love you white box know with Tommy
Mars that I was like,
I just,
you know,
I was keeping an eye on him.
How'd you feel that?
The Ray Mercer.
Oh my God.
After that,
that was the worst thing I've ever seen
in my life.
That knockout was so good that my friend
Kevin,
who is like a huge fan of Tommy Morrison
was,
was like,
he wasn't even bummed out.
He was like,
damn,
that dude's awesome.
Just saying that,
you know,
ray mercer was so awesome.
Even though he was rooting for Tommy,
it was such a brutal knockout.
They just wanted to see rand mercer
fight again.
So good cuts of Ray Mercer whispering
and the guys a year,
a few years later,
like,
please take it down.
I'll give you half the money.
Who did he say that to?
I forget,
but it was like a core TV case.
Oh,
that's right.
Oh my God.
When they were in the clinch,
he goes,
take a dive.
I'll give you half the money once that
was it Bobby Chez?
No.
Who was it that he had a fight with?
He had a fight with someone and it was
an important.
If you lost the fight,
he was not going to get a title shot.
Yeah.
So he was.
That's right.
Or allegedly he asked him.
I don't know if that's true.
I don't know if you ever been proven.
Was it ever proven you can look it up?
I think he may have been found guilty of
that.
Maybe.
I don't know if you ever watch that
documentary.
Speaking of boxing,
but the guy,
what was his name?
Where they,
they made his inside of his gloves.
So Resto?
Yeah.
Yeah,
they fucked it was billy,
Billy Collins Jr.
He claims he didn't know he claims he
didn't know.
YeaH,
that was a Panama lewis.
That was the same guy who doctored up.
Um,
uh,
aaron priors a drink.
He said,
don't give me that water.
Give me the other one.
The one that I fixed.
And then he gives it to aaron pryor and
aaron pryor goes out there like a
fucking bat out of hell and knocks out
alexis are way on the next round.
And they said it was some sort of a
stimulant and problem.
Aaron pryor rather wind up having a bit
of a drug problem.
So rarely been,
could have been related in that way.
But um,
it's just weird how,
how the,
the,
the ferocity of the reactions when I
brought up this racism thing,
maybe it was like irresponsible on my
part,
but I'm,
I'm sort of happy that I brought it up
anyway just because I'm fascinated by
the response and I'm fascinated by no
black people disagreed with me.
That's the weird thing.
The weird thing is the guys who
disagreement,
I don't know everybody who disagree with
me on twitter,
so I'm kind of talking out of my ass
here,
but the people that I interact with on a
regular basis where their comics or
whatever,
they all thought it was.
The black guYs all thought it was very
valid that there's certain mount of like
extra judgment that you give a cocky
young black athlete and I was like,
that's fascinating.
I wonder if that's true.
Even just paying attention to that.
That's something I wonder.
I wonder what if a factor it is and it's
not.
It's not the only factor that there's
$350 million People on this planet in
this country rather,
and if you know,
if a million people like you in a
miLlion people hate you this fucking
wide variety of reasons,
but to say that out of all the millions
of people who know who you are,
that they're on a certain percentage of
them that are racist seems disingenuous.
I mean iT seems like there's a certain
amount of people across the board,
they're going to be racist.
If you have $350 million people.
I don't know how many people you're
going to get that the racist,
but there's gotta be a certain
percentage that has to be factored in
there.
Know,
seeing.
You wonder how much of it is.
I think the interesting thing is that I
think floyd mayweather,
people that hate him,
I bet there's a lot more racism involved
in that than jon jones.
Jon jones gives you a pretty valid
reasons.
It'd be like sky sort of a dick just
publicly from what you see,
you know,
I don't know anything about them other
than what I see in the press and on the
shows.
But I mean like maybe whether it's a guy
you know,
you see,
he's like,
you know,
the press is talking to him.
He's like throwing $100 bills,
you know,
just like a master showman.
That regard too though.
But that personality feeds into someone
who's got racism in their heart.
That's really,
that fires them up.
Well.
I've read some horrific shit about.
Well,
I've read,
I've read some racist shit about both
guys,
about jon jones and about floyd
mayweather,
but this recent barrage of shit about
people like how much hate they have for
him after he fought my don and last.
YoU know,
I don't know if they were betting on my
door.
I don't know what it is,
but that's also how he sells tickets.
I mean he sells tickets by people
wanting
him to lose,
but he so fucking good.
You could bArely hit him if,
if he gets tagged once or twice hard and
a fight.
It's shocking and rare,
but there's a lot of fights where he'll
go like the entire fight to box in
someone's face off and not get hit at
all.
So for every sugar,
shane mosley who connects our.
Every madonna right righthand that
lands.
This is like a lot of rounds where he's
not even getting hit.
He's just slipping out of things,
move in and doing things to you that you
didn't expect and moving in a way that
you didn't anticipate and being nowhere
near you when you're looking to hit him.
You know,
he's a master,
but he's also a master at manipulation,
mean he's playing the heel where I think
john is just a young guy figuring it out
on his own while he's one of the baddest
man on the planet at 25 years of age and
he's had this ridiculous rise to success
that happened in a really short period
of time.
Like from the time he was like 21 years
old to the time that he's 25 starts
martial arts and becomes the light
heavyweight champion.
I mean tHat's fucking crazy,
man.
He had a martial art background because
he was a really good wrestler and did
know some kicking and punching and stuff
before he started into mma,
but he got into mma because he got his
girlfriend pregnant and he,
you know,
he couldn't go to college.
He wanted to do the right thing and
said,
all right,
fuck it.
I'll start fighting and then got into it
and he's a crazy road for anybody to
take and to be that popular in that
famous at 25,
you're going to fuck up man.
But there was going to make mistakes.
You got to watch.
Can you almost pinpoint what it is when
the switch flipped on him?
I remember like I saw I went to,
I went to ufc 101,
uh,
in philly,
forrest griffin versus a silver and
there he was walking around a jon jones
is one brand and I remember,
uh,
my buddy dave was with me was like,
there's jon jones.
He's like,
that Guy is bad ass and he's going to be
the next chair.
Like he was just really pumping up like
saying how great he was and how fun of a
young boy.
And then I started paying attention to
more and he was amazing.
And then just one day just seems like
people were like,
what a dick.
Some people.
Yeah.
When people want you to be perfect,
they're looking for flaws too bad
motherfucker cheating was the first
thing I saw.
He didn't do anything wrong in that.
What do you mean?
I thought it was weird that he dropped
him afterwards.
I know it's an aggressive situation,
but I think dropping a guy that he said
he knew it was unconscious was.
It was.
It was kind of shitty for a sport where
I thought,
I thought this is all supposed to be
handshakes at the end.
I see what you're saying.
That mode though.
You could hear a.
But when he walks over,
it's funny,
greg jackson,
that you could hear him say to me.
He goes,
john goes,
go when these people back and go check
out if he's okay.
He says,
he goes,
go check if he's okay,
They'll get some fan.
Yeah,
go get some fans.
Yeah.
No,
that's true.
Um,
I think,
but also I think to be a bad
motherfucker at that high level,
like a lot of times these guys are so
intense that they get completely caught
up in it and they just trapped in the
moment.
I think I know the dude.
I know him from backstage.
I know him from when he's not fighting
and he's really friendly.
He's really good,
but I wouldn't want to be fighting them.
I think if you're competing against him,
I think he's all those that are at the
top of the
heap there,
pretty fucking ferocious and some guys
are better at keeping it together in
scenarios like that where they don't
drop the guy.
Some guys aren't.
You know what I mean?
Dan henderson is one of the greatest of
all times,
one of the most famous moments in his
career as he knocked out michael bisping
with his vicious right hand and bisping
went soaring.
I mean he was out cold and henderson
dropped one on him.
He afterwards,
he talked about it in the post fight
interview.
How he dropped one on it.
I mean that's common.
So the last one was really running his
mouth kind of thing.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Baba lou,
who's another famous mixed martial arts
fighter,
a great fighter who fought in a bunch of
different organizations.
He lost his gig with the ufc pArtially
because he held onto this guy after he
was done choking them and then talked
about it in the post fight precedent
interview with me,
you know,
and I'm.
That guy was not doing anything that bj
penn hadn't done.
Bj penn did the sAme thing that jens
pulver like paula was tapping.
He's still fucking hung onto it because
they were angry at each other,
but Pulver didn't go out,
you know,
and for whatever reason,
him holding thAt choke for an extra
couple of seconds was okay.
Whereas bob blues guy went out and then
he talked about it,
but everybody knows why they do live.
Sure they do it because they're fucking
caught uP in all the trash talking and
all the bullshit and you know,
it is important that a fighter let go
and a referee tell them not to,
but it's understandable how these guys
get caught up in that.
It's understandable.
It's got to stop doing it,
but what john did technically is not.
There's nothing wrong with it because
when the referee came over to him,
he didn't keep hanging onto it.
That would have been a more agregious
example.
More and more,
you know,
but it is one of those things where you
appreciate like nate marquardt fought
this guy,
damien maia knocked him out with one
punch.
Damien was dazed but still conscious and
marquardt hovered over him and pulled
back,
realized he was out of it.
The referee stepped in and stopped it,
but nate easily could have dropped a
bomb on him and he didn't end.
It was a really classy move and people
really respected that,
that he did that and I made sure I
talked about it in the commentary.
That is a very classy move for jones
used to do that.
Whereas you and she's like homeless,
look at the ref like stopped and did
that with vinny pazienza.
He looked over at the ref and he's like,
come on man,
stop the fight.
The referee said no.
He said okay,
and then he went and dropped him again.
You know,
and yeah,
didn't mean there's moments because I
think an interesting thing when once you
lose your mojo,
man,
it's amazing,
isn't it?
Amazing.
Boy jones overnight went from like still
doing amazing things and then he lost
it.
He lost again and he lost.
It can go.
It's like once you stop believing in
yourself as an athlete,
like you believe it is a lot to do with
you believing you're indestructible.
Once you see that chicken,
your own armor,
man,
getting that,
getting that energy back up to do it
again must be really,
really hard.
Yeah,
I guarantee and there was a lot of other
factors involved in roy too because he
went up to heAvyweight and then really
how to dehydrate himself and we can
absolve very badly getting back down the
light heavyweight again and then he got
knocked out.
I mean he fought.
I'm Alan Johnson right now.
Glenn knocked him out after god dammit,
I can't believe harbor.
Yes.
Antonio tarver tarpon knocked him out.
Tara was the first guy to stop him and
he did it in a fight where it was a
rematch of a fight that they had that
was very close,
and then roy went up to heavyweight.
He box John Ruiz and beat him for the
title.
Then came down to light heavyweight and
in losing that 25 pounds,
he really dehydrated the shit out of
himself.
He looked terrible.
He looked like he had starved is he lost
all of his,
like his,
his like hardness to his muscles.
He looked terrible.
It was a really ugly weight cut and he
might've been done some shit to get up
to heavyweight too.
That's possible.
And then you get off that shit.
Your hormone levels crash.
That's a speculation,
but the bottom line was tarver knocked
him out and when tarver connected and
carver was a big puncher and we
connected and knocked them out,
roy was never the same.
Then the glen johnson fight with scary.
It's never the same.
It's just one day just happens.
It's Mike Tyson was never to say lennox
lewis.
Yeah.
He was never the same necessarily after
jail,
but he's still pretty ferocious.
They have to do well.
He tyson went to jail after he lost the
title.
Tyson and last and then went to jail and
came back was still fucking for
ferocious.
The difference in like whAt happened
with roy's at roy fought again,
like within a certain amount of time it
got knocked out really bad and when you
get knocked out by a guy,
when you get your brain's scrambled like
it takes a long time for tea.
It looks like freddy roach is a genius
and one of the things that he did
brilliantly with manny pacquiao is after
pack y'all got knocked out.
He told him like,
you're not going to fight for a year.
He's like,
take your head out of this like there's
no more.
We're gonna.
That was a bad knockout.
And freddy is a guy who suffers from a
trauma related parkinson's himself.
He's got the shakes from his career in
boxing and so because of that he's
super,
super aware of damage and he's like,
look,
you could be okay,
but you got to heal up like there's no
contact for a long time.
You're going to not fight for a year.
And then he came back a year later and
he looked great.
He looked like manny pacquiao and it's.
I think that rest time is super
important.
That recuperation time.
It's very important when god gets
knocked out and so we saw roy get beat
by that guy or get beat by tarver and
then beat again by johnson and a really
scary way.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's what he went through the ropes.
Well,
he went down and back to his.
He banged his head off the ground and he
was stiff at the end of the fight.
Like he was like stiff in this weird,
scary way and it,
it didn't look like the kind of punch
that would do that to you.
Like it didn't look like the kind of
punch that would really put you in a
catatonic state.
Like that was.
That was scary as shit man.
It wAs also scared because Roy Jones,
you know,
he used to be invincible.
Yeah,
that's what I mean.
Watching that haPpen to people is very,
you know,
watching like,
you know Michael Jordan number 45,
come back on the Washington wizards,
you know,
you're like,
well it's like watching Michael Jordan
play baseball.
Yeah.
That was the first thing I get them in.
Yeah,
that was definitely the first thing.
But I mean,
but to come back because he came back
and it was pretty great again,
but by the time he came back from
the wizards that one time it was like,
why?
Even like you never wanted to believe it
wouldn't be good anymore.
I never saw that.
I saw him.
He come back.
That was tough to watch.
I that with a being from philly iverson
when he came back for like did like 16
games before he left again.
And to have some weird situation where
like when he gets to be 50,
he gets like some giant chunk of money
apparently.
Yeah.
Either with a reebok.
Yes.
And kind of like the like trust or
something a weird.
but he's broken out right now.
That's what they say.
At least that he was begging for money.
It will.
AS it turned out it was bullshit.
right?
Wasn't that a bullshit story?
They're begging for and they just
retired his number.
He looks fine,
you know,
like no,
somebody was.
Somebody was saying that he was outside
of a mall asking for money.
But then I think that turned out to be
like bullshit rumor that someone
started.
Yeah,
that's absolutely.
I heard marilyn manson lives above a
liquor store here in la.
There's no might.
He might do that just to be a fucking
crazy person.
Marilyn manson is the real deal.
Dude.
Talk to stan stan.
Hope now he's moments my favorite rock
star of all time.
do you know?
Stand up?
Yeah.
Do you need to talk to stan?
Hope about manson.
They hung out.
Oh good lord.
Really?
Oh,
I don't want to say anything on the air.
It's not my place.
But go ask.
He's,
he's not playing games.
Sounds like an absence story that
involves a lot of different things.
You need to hear it all from standing
up.
I will look into that.
Mellon manson or talked to tate
fletcher.
Fletcher's hung out with them too.
I've never met marilyn manson because
uh,
for the same reason.
Every time I see dice,
I never really talked to him because I'm
like,
if this guy's a douche bag to me,
it's going to just destroy my thing.
Dice would be cool to you.
If you're a comic on bobby kelly's
podcast,
they made me read it.
I wrote him.
I got stolen one night and just this is,
this should have happened 15 years ago,
not a year and a half ago.
I wrote him some faceBook.
He loved letter and the return thing was
like,
ah,
this is actually licensed assistant.
He doesn't really check it.
Yes.
Oh,
I gave them references to who to ask
about me,
you know?
How long had you been doing comedy when
you did that?
Fourteen years.
It was a year and a half ago.
I got stoned and I was like,
oh,
you know what it was.
I got stolen that I was listening to
dice.
Man cometh and dice bank.
Come with whoa.
Look as a,
as a professional adult comic now doing
it many years,
like I,
I see the holes and everyone's game.
I'll wait.
You know what I mean?
Like I don't.
There's no pedestal that I have mom,
except for the fact that dice when I was
younger,
I loved him.
It was my favorite thing in the world,
was part of the reason I would be funny.
Like I would go to school and recite
dice lines and it was also a bonding
thing that me and my step,
my step pup started dating my mom and
staying over and everything like that.
Like he would let me watch dice,
like he brought that into my life.
That was our,
like our bonding thing that we both just
loved ice.
So now when I see him,
just one of those guys just like you,
that I just,
somehow we haven't crossed paths and uh,
I've seen him once them once in a while
I'm like,
I'm to go talk to them and I just don't.
well,
if I'm ever around them and you're
around them,
I'll introduce
you.
he's great.
He's fun and he's been on the podcast a
bunch of time.
He's been great on the puck.
Yeah.
I hung out with him in norton and
anthony and uh,
it was as a bunch of us and brian and
who else was with us was Bobby Kelly?
No,
it wasn't Bobby Kelly.
Kelly.
Yeah.
Bobby kelly was there too.
And we all saw him.
We went to his show and uh,
in vegas at the riviera.
Nice.
Which is the classic venue place I've
ever played.
Hasn't changed since 1970.
I mean,
they haven't done a goddamn thing.
They've washed the floor.
That's it.
At the comedy club?
Yeah.
The upstairs right across from the
dancing girls shows that the above
thing.
Theater.
They used to have the frank marino drag
show in drag queen show.
Did you ever see that?
No.
Oh,
it was great.
He's like,
the lady is a queen.
I think like he has like a,
like a book out about being a cross
dresser.
He's do a whole show where he would like
cross dress this guy and he's like a
famous crossdresser for vegas.
Like one of those guys were like,
you really didn't see him or hear about
them anywhere else.
But If you're in vegas like frank
marino,
you'd see his name on these calves,
like the little triangle that sits on
top of the cab.
You know what I'm talking about?
That the little billboard they have that
they ran out and uh,
so dice had that room was like the
upstairs room.
It's a larger room and we went to see it
were howling like little school children
and then the after it was over we were
hanging out backstage and I was like,
holy shit.
I'm backstage with dice.
Like I was thinking about like being a
kid and listening to his.
It was a cassette.
Yeah.
My rules was just dice.
I think the first one was just dice,
you know,
and I was listening to it.
This girl I was dating,
we were crying,
laughing.
We thought it was so funny because back
then it was like so shocking what he was
saying.
Anytime time someone dismisses dice,
I always go,
he goes,
he's having a hard time making friends.
So I go to see the psycho therapist and
I'm like,
hey doc,
I'm having a hard time making friends.
You fucking cock sucker.
Like if you told me that's not funny,
you just don't know what's funny.
That's funny.
Well,
he,
you know,
if you know his story that that dice
part was a character.
Yep.
Oh yeah.
No,
I mean just from being a fan,
but I heard him on your thing to tell
the whole story and everything,
but it's weird.
It's weird that he acknowledges that
being a character and still in a weird
way chooses to live as the character.
He likes it.
He likes being.
That guy looks were in wrestling sort of
a fucking joey.
Joey buttafuoco sweatshirts and shit.
He was the cut weightlifting gloves.
Oh,
you're could do flashdance flashdance
shirts used to wear the gold's gym
jacket everywhere.
It's great.
The way he came out on that,
uh,
the one he did in the round.
The special.
Yeah.
Was just the headband with the big
feather,
like staying alive hair.
Will you ever hear him talking about how
he tried to move back to brooklyn to.
Oh,
it's hilarious.
Yeah.
He just tried to move back with those
animals.
Don't like,
like after he became the dice man,
I'm going to go back to the
neighborhood,
get put up a fence and hide behind me.
He can't.
It's the same hanging around with those
people.
It's an interesting.
I'd be curious to find out if larry the
cable guy,
like he's like,
hey,
hey babe,
I gotta run to the hardware store or
whatever.
You know,
I'm sure it doesn't do that,
but whatever I have to go out for,
if he has to go throw in like a
sleeveless flannel shirt,
he can go back.
I mean he's like a tucked in shirt guy.
Well he that is a complete and total dan
whitney.
But does he,
I mean he did.
He almost committed to living his life.
Now is larry the cable guy?
He sort of passed the test too.
I mean if he ever went out as dan
whitney or did an interview on the view,
he's one of the few real characters in
standup was like if he went on the view.
I don't know why I keep saying the view.
If you went on the jimmy fallon show,
the tonight show and he went on his dan
whitney,
it would probably blow his whole fucking
thIng.
Well,
it isn't that what happened when you can
almost pinpoint the change in diocese
career trajectory was when he cried in
our centennial hall.
He humanized himself too much,
whIch some people probably thought it
was a cool thing,
but when he cried about like,
you know,
dice man supposed to come out and be
like,
you know,
they were taking a movie out of the
theater that was as beef and he got
teary eyed,
but if before he sees,
you know,
dice is supposed to come out and be like
fuck you don't see my movie.
Huge watts.
But he cried or sydney hall and it was
real.
It was a genuine moment and that's just,
you know,
that's not who he is.
But I think he was also under some
insane pressure.
Like if you don't remember what it was
like back then,
like there was so many people that were
angry to meet me and he had like some
hateful comedy.
Yeah,
lIke the things that he was making,
like the way he was making fun of it.
It's like if you go back and listen to
like eddie murphy raw,
if you go back and see some of the gay
stuff,
like it was like really aggressively
anti gay,
like the comic strip in New York.
I've told us on so many radio shows,
but it does make me laugh that how
things have changed and no one comes
down with eddie murphy ever for this
stuff,
but they have to have is gold albums on
the wall and the first one track for
just called faggots and then track one
on the next album is causa says faggots
and then parentheses says revisited that
we didn't cover it all in the first go
around.
Well it's in that way like social
justice warriors as it were a kind of
important because that's the only reason
why a lot of thIs change has taken
places because of how outraged people
got.
Like if people just kept quiet about it
back then.
So in a way like a lot of the,
the old like taking it too far,
like sort of bounces back and it has a
healthy middle.
You know what I mean?
Like in some ways like there's always
going to be like the far left,
but in a lot of ways the far left
tempers the far right.
It's like,
because like the standard,
it'd be,
it changes,
it moves back and forth,
like if you,
if you let people go and,
and you know,
be as racist and homophobic and as
hateful as they want and don't do
anything about it.
They kind of never realized that where
they're doing it shitty.
But because of
the blowback,
like dice all that crying and everything
that he did,
that's probably a direct result of
blowback.
Like he's probably like,
he was constantly experiencing people
that were protesting.
Remember he got kicked off of mt for,
for lIfe.
And I remember kurt loder saying about
how unfunny it was,
and this is not like unfunny to who to
you.
Okay.
I guarantee you if he did that late
night at the comedy store,
he would fucking crush.
So like,
are you recognizing this as a character
or do you think there's a real person
who's saying these real things and you
don't think there's any comedy in this,
this play that he's putting on,
which is essentially he's pretending to
be this soulful guy.
Oh,
you cock sucker like this.
He's going to fuck a guy's chicken in
front of them.
It's obvious that he doesn't really
mean.
I mean it's like five minutes left.
So he's doing.
There's some craziness to it is.
I mean it's a character.
I mean,
is that,
is there a difference between that
character in the bad guy character in a
movie where the guy's going to run
around killing people or raping people
or is there a difference?
I mean it is just fiction.
Like how come we don't hold the actor
responsible because the actor didn't
write it.
If he wrote it and he wanted to be,
the bad guy would be.
We'd be upset at them.
No,
it's like for that kind of comedy,
but I mean,
but there's also,
you don't have to do a character to say.
I feel like I feel like the entire
disclaimer of everything goes to,
like I said earlier,
it's like there's a laughing microphone
behind you on a wall.
Like we're not.
You know what I mean?
Like I'm not addressing,
you know,
the state of the state of the union.
You know what I mean?
Like I'm up here telling you like,
it's clearly.
That was always my thing about,
uh,
with the taj,
the lady getting so mad.
It's like,
do you believe for one split second that
daniel tosh is pro rape and as slipped
through the cracks to find himself
massive television success?
do you believe that?
That doesn't happen?
It doesn't happen.
That would have reared its head before.
It's not what they're saying.
What they're saying is they found a
green light.
They found a green light to be outraged
and you know,
also some people way more sensitive than
others,
you know,
being called out in front of all those
people have.
And everybody laugh aT what he said to
her probably sucked for her.
She decided that she was,
for whatever reason,
she was justified and proving our point
or making her point or expressing
herself,
which you know,
you should be allowed to express
yourself,
but the idea that he's supposed to
apologize for that.
Like if you look at what it was on paper
and then they hear comics agreeing with
them,
that was just disappointing.
But your outrageous supposed to come at
like oppression,
injustice,
whatever semester you're supposed to
like rage against the art.
You know what I mean?
Like in a clear,
the creatives fucking around situation
where someone's just fucking around.
IT's clear he's adlibbing.
This is not a thought out piece.
You know where he's advocating a woman,
a random woman getting raped for no
reason other than the klan rallies.
What I'm saying,
it's there.
You're in an environment.
If this is what it is,
well you know what man?
Some people be really happy if everybody
was exactly like them.
If everybody had the same sensibilities,
sensibilities,
sensitivities,
and everybody had the same ideas about
what's important to talk about,
what you can't talk about,
what's taboo,
what's okay.
You know,
there's plenty of people out there that
agree and disagree and they're fucking
going at it back and forth.
That's what's fascinating.
That's fascinating about trying to find
out where's the middle ground,
like how much of it is me being crazy?
How much of it is me just tapping into
one mindset with whatever thing you
support or disagree with anything,
whether it's the style of comedy that
people do or the kind of music that
people are into.
Some fucking kid got arrested because he
took some lyrics to a song and put it
up,
put the lyrIcs up as a tweet and they
arrested him because it was like some
fucking crazy.
You're right.
Some song about school shootings.
Oh,
it was going to say it wasn't for like
the actual copyright of the song.
You're saying?
No,
no,
he.
They came.
They arrested him because he tweeted
some in the band.
I forget what the show's almost over.
I forget what the band's name was that
came to his defense,
but they're like,
this is the lyrics to a song.
It's like an anti school shooting song,
you know,
but it's like talking about like where
this all comes from the rate.
I don't know if it's an anti schools
shooting song,
but it's just a song and it's coming
from like the rage of like where,
where,
where's this guy feeling?
what is this guy doing?
This guy tweeted this.
These lyrics,
like if you tweet something from a movie
about like kill them all,
let god sort about like,
does that mean I'm going to go out and
kill people?
I mean gus van sant and made a hole
basically a columbine movie.
Yeah,
right.
Do.
If I remember he did that movie though.
we added in for some reason was before
they went to do the murder,
they just got in the shower together and
made our elephant.
He just added that in there before they
went to go shoot.
It was all the same thing like filming
themselves and planning the whole thing
for weeks and getting the guns together
and then right before school that
morning they just hopped in the shower
and started making out the two dudes.
Nothing about that ever in the real
story.
That was how he made it.
Like,
you know,
oh no,
this isn't the columbIne story these
kids were making out in the shower
first.
Wow.
That's pretty clever of him.
And on that note,
big jay oakerson.
Thank you very much brother.
There's a lot of.
I think we could do like 180 days.
Okay.
Well,
you know,
anytime I come out at all.
Anytime.
How often are you out here?
I'm trying to come out more.
I'm checking them out like three times a
year at least.
Beautiful.
And you're on ari shapiro storyteller
show that's online and you're doing the
weather like during the one for tv
tonight,
so I think there's probably some tickets
available or he was upset that they were
in moving quick enough.
People just didn't know about it,
but they're available for free.
Contact orisha fear on twitter and he
will respond to you and get you tickets
for free.
Big jay oakerson on twitter.
Which website?
A bigj comedy,
big j dot comedy.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Thank you brother.
Have to do.
Thanks for often times.
Amazing.
Thanks to our sponsor and thanks to
squarespace.
Go to squarespace.com.
Use the code word rogan and save 10
percent off your first
purchase@squarespace.com.
And in the codeword rogan.
Thanks also to legal zoom.
Enter the code word rogan at the
referral box at checkout legal zoom.
An awesome way to do legal shit from the
comfort of your own home.
And last but not least,
thanks to [inaudible] dot com,
it's o n n I t use the code word rogan
and save 10 percent off any and all
supplements.
All right,
we'll be
back tomorrow with rupert sheldrake and
then thursday with graham hancock.
See you soon.
Bye bye.
Oh.